Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio in Blumen hier auf Fritz. Jeden zweiten letzten Donnerstag am Monat, das ist ja ganz einfach zu merken, gibt es hier das Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wo Leute vom Chaos Computer Club kommen und über Dinge reden, die mit dieser digitalen Welt zu tun haben, die ja möglicherweise sich vielleicht bald doch irgendwie durchsetzen wird. Und heute begrüße ich ganz herzlich Danimo. Hallo und guten Abend. Guten Abend. Und Andreas Bog. Hallo und guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und es soll heute im weiteren Verlauf des Abends, das kann ich gleich sagen, um Sicherheitslücken, Hacker, ihre Software gehen und wie man damit umgeht. Weil es in der letzten Zeit ein paar interessante, wie man es immer Sicherheitsschwankungen gab, die man mal genauer beleuchten müsste. Aber aus aktuellem Anlass ziehen wir vorher noch etwas anderes ein. Und zwar kennt ihr vielleicht das Blog netzpolitik.org. Das ist ein Blog, das ist hier in Berlin ansässig. Das berichtet sehr, sehr, sehr viel über das, was netzpolitisch im Land so abgeht. Ist eine sehr kritische, sehr gern gehörte Stimme und auf jeden Fall eine sehr weitgehörte Stimme. Und die sind, so ist heute bekannt geworden, oder gegen die ist ein Ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet worden. Wegen, haltet euch fest, Landesverrats. Und weil die Leute von Netzpolitik hier auch häufiger schon mal zu Gast waren, natürlich jetzt genau wissen wollen, also Entschuldigung so, Landesverräter hier beim Chaosradio zu Gast. Was ist denn da los? Sprechen wir jetzt mit Markus Becke dal, Gründer von netzpolitik.org und mittlerweile da Chef. Hallo und guten Abend. So, ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Landesverrat, was genau ist da passiert?
Wir haben im Februar und im April in zwei Artikeln darüber berichtet, dass die Antwort der Bundesregierung auf die Snowden-Enthüllungen mehr Kompetenzen und Geld für den Verfassungsschutz sind, der seine Internetüberwachung ausbauen soll mit diesem Geld. Und wir fanden das ein Skandal und wir brauchen eine gesellschaftliche Debatte, ob die richtige Antwort auf die Snowden-Enthüllungen mehr Überwachung oder vielleicht weniger Überwachung sein sollte. Und wir haben darüber berichtet, dass der Verfassungsschutz jetzt zukünftig verstärkt in sozialen Netzwerken Rasterfahndung machen soll, was aus unserer Sicht einige Verfassungsfragen aufwirft. Und haben auch dazu Ausschnitte aus den Haushaltsplänen des Verfassungsschutzes online gestellt, damit sich jeder Leser auch aus den originalen Dokumenten informieren kann, die quasi diesen Zufachs an Kompetenzen für Internetüberbruchung belegen. Und genau deswegen wird jetzt wegen Asperat gegen uns ermittelt.
Weil diese Dokumente irgendwie geheim waren?
Ja, diese Dokumente waren geheim eingestuft. Normalerweise liegen sie Journalisten vor. In diesem Fall haben wir uns dafür entschieden, sie online zu stellen. Einerseits, weil wir noch Platz auf dem Server hatten und weil wir der Meinung sind, dass sich auch kritische Bürger aus Originalquellen selbst informieren können sollten. Auch um die Arbeit von Journalisten überprüfen und kontrollieren zu können. Und wir waren auch der Meinung, in diesem Fall macht es Sinn, diese Dokumente online zu stellen, um dieses Ausmaß und eigentlich dieses Grupellosigkeit dieser Bundesregierung zwei Jahre nach Snowden einfach die Überwachung noch weiter auszubauen. Besser dokumentiert, wer sein würde.
Jetzt können wir trotzdem sagen, also jetzt mal die Absicht dahingestellt, geheime Dokumente zu veröffentlichen. Das gibt unter Umständen Ärger. Seid ihr damit ein Einzelfall? Seid ihr die einzigen Leute, die jemals ein solches geheimes Dokument veröffentlicht haben? Oder macht man das eigentlich regelmäßig und euch hat es jetzt nur erwischt?
Na in der Regel liegen solche Dokumente an Journalisten vor. Das hat auch damit zu tun, dass es eigentlich damals in Vorinternetzeiten wenig Platz gab, um original Dokumente in einer Zeitung mit abzudrucken. Deswegen hat man daraus immer zitiert und wir haben sozusagen diesen alten Rattenschwanz nicht gekommen aus dem Netz. Wir sind gewöhnt darauf, auf Originalquellen zu verlinken. Deswegen haben wir sie online gestellt. Aber sagen wir mal, das Vorgehen des Generalbundesanwaltes gegen Journalisten, gegen Landesverrat zu ermitteln, das kam wohl in der Geschichte der Deutschen Bundesrepublik nur einmal vor. Und das war vor jetzt 53 Jahren gegen den Spiegel im Rahmen der sogenannten Spiegelaffäre.
Dann ist ja immer die Frage nach den Konsequenzen. Also dann erstmal in der Vergangenheit, wie ist die Spiegelaffäre ausgegangen?
Naja, der Spiegel-Herausgeber Auchstein musste drei Monate lang in Beu gehabt. Und hinterher ist dann Franz Josef Strauß als Verteidigungsminister zurückgetreten, konnte aber immer noch Ministerpräsident von Bayern werden, zum Glück nicht Kanzler.
Das hieße dann übersetzt, das wäre, na egal, das können wir dann später sehen. Wie ist das denn jetzt bei euch? Also was droht euch denn im schlimmsten Fall?
Also wir mussten uns auch erstmal informieren, was denn quasi Verrat von Landesverrat mit sich bringt. Wenn wir dessen überführt werden, dann drohen uns mindestens ein Jahr Knast. Und zwar für André, der den Artikel geschrieben hat und für mich als Verantwortlichen im Sinne des Presserechts. Also wenn wir Pech haben, dann kommen wir ins Gefängnis dafür, dass wir aufgedeckt haben, dass der Verfassungsschutz in Zeiten von Snowden-Enthüllungen im Geheimen massiv aufgerüstet wird, um verstärkt in sozialen Netzwerken eine Rasterfahnung durchzuführen, die wahrscheinlich aus unserer Sicht verfassungswidrig sein könnte. Weil der Verfassungsschutz darf eigentlich nur in Einzelfällen ermitteln und darf nicht einfach eine riesige Rasterfahnung machen. Das schreibt das Grundgesetz vor.
Jetzt ist es ja so, es gab schon zahlreiche Reaktionen, das ist ja heute Nachmittag irgendwie rausgekommen. Wie sind die denn so? Also es war ja sehr breite Unterstützung, was ich vor allen Dingen gesehen habe.
Also wir sind sehr positiv überrascht, dass sehr viele Menschen uns dadurch unterstützen, dass sie die Artikel weiter verteilen, dass sie jetzt Spenden aufrufen. Wir finanzieren unsere Arbeit vor allen Dingen durch Spenden, die ermöglichen uns solche investigativen Recherchen zu machen und unabhängig von Werbung. Ansonsten freuen wir uns über die Solidarität von vielen anderen Medien. Wir haben gerade mal so im Netz geschaut, auf fast allen großen Medienseiten ist das die Aufmachergeschichte. Das freut uns, weil wir hoffen, dass uns diese Aufmerksamkeit hilft, nämlich dass die Bundesregierung, die offensichtlich diese Strafanzeigen und die Ermittlungen deckt, irgendwann das Gefühl bekommt, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen falsch ist aus Sicht der Gesellschaft.
Jetzt wie ist es denn mit politischen Reaktionen? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, so große Koalition hält sich jetzt vielleicht eher bedeckt. Gab es ansonsten politische Reaktionen?
Naja, also wir haben von Parteien, die früher mal im Bundestag waren oder gerne im Bundestag kommen würden, viel Unterstützung erhalten. Wir haben aber auch von den Linken, von den Grünen, auch von einzelnen SPD-Abgeordneten bisher was gehört. Nur die CDU, CSU, da haben wir noch überhaupt nichts gehört. Die ist total still und traut sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu sagen, dass sie das wahrscheinlich gut findet.
Wie ist denn jetzt das weitere Vorgehen?
Ja, wissen wir nicht. Also ich meine, heute Morgen bin ich aufgewacht und dachte, wir haben jetzt Sommer und können uns schön entspannen. Passiert nicht so viel. Wir sind jetzt erstmal im Dialog mit vielen Rechtsanwälten. Wir müssen erstmal herausfinden, was bedeutet das konkret? Wie müssen wir uns möglicherweise auch verhalten? Das kann ja auch so sein, dass jetzt morgen irgendwie eine Hausdurchsuchung bei uns zu Hause und in unseren Redaktionsräumen stattfindet. Das sind alles so Fragestellungen, mit denen möchte man sich eigentlich nicht beschäftigen, wenn man Journalist ist und sich für Grundrechte einsetzt. Aber das müssen wir jetzt und insofern werden wir mal schauen, was so morgen passiert, wie die Reaktionen weiterhin sind und was man vielleicht auch aus der Politik hört. Weil wir gehen davon aus, dass diese ganzen Strafanzeigen und die Einleitung von Ermittlungen garantiert vom Innenministerium und vom Justizministerium gedeckt sind, wahrscheinlich auch vom Kanzleramt.
Wir haben im Vorfeld der Sendung so ein bisschen spekuliert, was das alles bedeutet. Und da kam zum Beispiel auch die Idee auf, wenn man jetzt wirklich nur an dieser Strafverfolgung interessiert wäre, da hätte man vielleicht eher die Tür eingetreten und erst mal alle Rechner beschlagnahmt. So hat man euch das größtmögliche Spielfeld gegeben, um diese Meldung rauszubringen und zu sagen, hier guckt, wir werden jetzt gerade Ermittlungsverfahren. Was glaubt ihr denn steckt dahinter? Also, geht es wirklich um dieses Verfahren oder ist es eher so ein Drohgebärde?
Also wir sehen das ganz klar als Einschüchterungsversuch an. Nicht nur gegen uns, aber vor allen Dingen auch gegen uns, weil wir in den letzten Monaten, auch im letzten Jahr vor allen Dingen, seit Beginn der Soundenthüllung eine ganze Menge mitgeholfen haben, aufzudecken und gesellschaftliche Debatten anzustoßen. Aber da gibt es auch andere Medien, viel größere Medien, die dasselbe machen. Insofern vermuten wir, dass die Bundesregierung, dass die Sicherheitsbehörden nicht bedrauten, zum Beispiel gegen den Spiegel vorzugehen und dachten, sie nehmen jetzt uns als kleines Blog um dieselbe Botschaft, auch an alle Journalisten und auch an alle potentiellen Quellen in den Sicherheitsbehörden, im politischen Berlin zu senden, dass jetzt scharf zurückgeschossen wird, wenn weiterhin dabei mitgeholfen wird, diesen größten Überwachungsskandal in der Geschichte der Menschheit einfach aufzudecken und aufzuklären.
Markus Beckendahl vom Blog Netzpolitik Org ist angeklagt wegen Landesverrat. Wir sind sehr gespannt, wie das ausgeht, wir natürlich weiter hier berichten. Ansonsten könnt ihr euch selber ein Bild davon machen, sowohl von der Arbeit als auch über die ganze Geschichte, die wir jetzt gerade erzählt haben, aus netzpolitik.org. Markus, vielen Dank und viel Glück. Dann wird gefeiert im Hintergrund. Na dann viel Spaß noch. So, so viel dazu, das mussten wir gleich noch einziehen, weil das war wirklich, ist aktuell heute passiert und da wollten wir euch nicht dem Unklaren drüber lassen. Die angewesenen Herren, Andreas und Danimo vom Chaos Computer Club, wollt ihr noch kurz dazu was sagen? Hat euch das jetzt überrascht, dass das passiert ist?
Also ich finde es schon sehr überraschend, vor allen Dingen angesichts der historischen Dimension. Markus hat es gerade schon erwähnt, das letzte Mal, dass Journalisten wegen Landesverrats angeklagt wurden, war 1962 im Rahmen der Spiegel-Affäre. Da ging es darum, dass der Spiegel über interne Pläne der Bundeswehr berichtete. Und es ging um den Ost-West-Konflikt und dass die Bundeswehr nicht in der Lage wäre, aktuell das zu leisten, was sie leisten sollte, um gegen den bösen Russen zu verteidigen. Ganz grob gesprochen. Und das war halt ein Riesending mit Journalisten, die verhaftet wurden, Hausdurchsuchungen. Wir haben es gehört, Franz Josef Strauß musste als Verteidigungsminister zurücktreten. Das wurde damals in der internationalen Presse verglichen mit dem Prozess im Karl von Osiecki, der 1931 darüber berichtet hat, dass die Reichswehr verbotene Aufrüstung betrieben hat, deswegen tatsächlich auch im Gefängnis gelandet ist, später von Nazis ins KZ gesteckt wurde, da auch gestorben ist, den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen hat. Also diese ganze Landesverratsgeschichte, das ist kein kleines Ding, das ist nicht so, naja, da hat mal jemand jemanden angezeigt. Und also allein die Tatsache, dass überhaupt schon Ermittlungen aufgenommen wurden, ist eine ganz unglaubliche Frechheit, weil der Staatsanwalt, auch der Generalbundesanwalt von Amts wegen verpflichtet ist, vor Aufnahme der Ermittlungen zu prüfen, ob denn da überhaupt Substanz dahinter ist. Das ist derselbe Generalbundesanwalt, der sich also weigert, in Sachen NSA Überwachung zu ermitteln, obwohl da ganz klare Beweise vorliegen, dass zum Beispiel gegen die Bundeskanzlerin abgehört wurde. Also das ist ein hochpolitisches Spiel, was da gespielt wird. Also ein ganz unglaublich großer Skandal, der sicherlich noch einige Zeit beschäftigen wird.
Sehr gespannt, vielleicht demnächst ein eigenes Chaosradio dazu. Wir schließen das jetzt erstmal ab, wollten euch sozusagen nur auf dem Laufenden halten, spielen jetzt eine kleine Musik und danach geht es um das eigentliche Thema. Da geht es um Sicherheitslücken, Sicherheitscodes und wie man damit umgeht. Bis gleich. Wenn ihr euch für Chipmusik interessiert, ist Lukasch ein Name, den man sich auf jeden Fall mal merken könnte. Der bringt ab und zu Sachen heraus, die wirklich wirklich gut sind. Another World war das und das ist auch zum Beispiel auch Netzmusik, die man sich sonst runterladen kann und weitergeben auch unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Mehr davon gibt's jedes Samstag hier bei Trackback auf Fritz. Ihr seid im Chaosradio der Blue Moon, der alle zwei Monate hier stattfindet und wo es um Dinge im Internet geht. Meistens mit Sicherheit haben die irgendwie zu tun, heute auch mit Lizenzen, wie auch bei diesem Song. Alles ein großes, weites Feld und das wollen wir zusammen mit Danimo. Hallo und guten Abend. Schönen guten Abend. Und mit Andreas Bruck. Hallo und guten Abend. Und es geht sehr mal schön, wenn man am Anfang so ein griffiges Ding hat, aber das ist gar nicht so einfach, weil das alles sehr groß ist.
Sag doch einfach mal Autos hacken.
Autos hacken.
Weil Autos betrifft alle. Das verstehen alle.
Das betrifft alle.
Also reden wir nicht nur drüber, aber...
Ja, aber es geht ja darum zu sagen, was macht man denn, wenn man so ein Auto gehackt hat? Also, wie geht man damit um? Oder wie geht man damit um, wenn man erfährt, dass andere Leute den eigenen Code, den man geschrieben hat, benutzt, um ein gehacktes Auto gegen eine Wand zu fahren? Oder an eine Menschenmenge? Oder was auch immer man mit gehackten Hubs machen kann. Dazu kommen wir heute im Laufe der Sendung auch. Und der größte Anlass, den ihr vielleicht gehört habt, der ist jetzt schon wieder zwei bis drei Wochen her, das ist das sogenannte Hacking Team. Das werden wir jetzt erstmal erläutern. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz spannende Geschichte, hört sich ein bisschen geheimagentenmäßig an. Denn es gibt in Italien eine Firma, die war eine Sicherheitsfirma und die ist gehackt worden. Und dann sind ein paar Dinge rausgekommen. Die würde ich gerne von euch mal genauer wissen. Hacking Team, was ist das eigentlich?
Ja, es gibt einen Haufen Firmen weltweit, die sich mit Computersicherheit beschäftigen. Der normale Fall ist, es sind halt ein paar Leute und man hat eine Webseite und dann sagt man, irgendwie könnt ihr euch mal unsere Webseite angucken, gibt ihnen Geld dafür. Dann schreiben sie einen Bericht rein, vielleicht solltet ihr das anders machen. Das ist so dein Normalfall. Das typische Consulting, Pentesting-Geschäft. Dann gibt es noch welche, die obendrauf noch Consulting machen. ISO 27000 ist wie ISO 9000 plus 18000 mehr. Qualitätsmanagement für IT-Sicherheit im Großunternehmen. Das ist ungefähr so staubtrocken, wie es klingt, bringt aber gutes Geld. Aber was noch viel, viel besseres Geld bringt, und da ist Hacking Team eigentlich eher die Ausnahme unter den Sicherheitsfirmen, vielleicht zusammen mit ein paar anderen Kandidaten, wie der Gamma Group. Die stellen tatsächlich Software her, um in anderer Leute Rechner einzubrechen und verkaufen das.
Das klingt aber nicht so legal, oder darf man das?
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Auffassungen drüber. Die geben sich halt eine große Mühe, nur an Regierungen, regierungsnahe Institutionen zu verkaufen. Damit fängt es an. Und dann ist es natürlich erstmal legal, weil als Regierung machst du ja in deinem Land die Gesetze und wenn du reinschreibst, ich darf das kaufen, dann darfst du das kaufen. Manchmal gibt es noch andere Probleme, nämlich in der Form von Exportrestriktionen. Da kommen wir vielleicht später nochmal drauf. Die spielen da auch eine Rolle. Das macht es dann vielleicht weniger legal. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es eigentlich dasselbe Geschäftsmodell, wie die Leute in den komischen Untergrundforen auch haben, nämlich in andere Leute Recheneinbrechen. Nur, dass es größtenteils legal ist, weil die Regierungen, die es kaufen, selber sagen dürfen, dass es legal ist.
Okay, aber ist das dann schon unmoralisch per se? Oder sagt man, das ist dann erstmal okay, weil es ja gesetzlich erlaubt ist?
Zwischen legal und legitim besteht ja ein feiner Unterschied. Ich finde das, was sie da tun, nicht besonders angemessen. In andere Leute Recheneinzubrechen ist ein Eingriff in die Grundrechte, in die persönliche Freiheit, in die informationelle Selbstbestimmung, wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat. Da müssen also schon sehr, sehr gewichtige Gründe vorliegen, um das überhaupt zu tun, wenn überhaupt. Ich finde es moralisch zweifelhaft. Zumal gerade im speziellen Fall von Hacking Team, und da müssen wir vielleicht ein bisschen ausholen, was wurde denn bei Hacking Team gehackt? Denen wurden im Prinzip ihre kompletten Daten geklaut, also ihre Rechnungsunterlagen, die Liste der Kunden, ihre E-Mails, der Source-Code und so weiter und so fort. Und anhand dieser Dokumente ließ sich nachvollziehen, wer denn alles diese Software gekauft hat, die wie gesagt dazu da ist, in andere Leute Rechner einzubrechen. Und da finden sich also durchaus einige Staaten auf der Liste, die sagen mal ein sehr robustes Verhältnis zu Freiheitsrechten haben.
Also zum Beispiel der Sudan, Bahrain, Saudi-Arabien, sowas in der Richtung. Also nur falls jetzt jemand nicht genau weiß, was ihr meint, könnt ihr mal beschreiben, was ihr damit meint.
Na das sind Länder, die sich eigentlich dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie keine Demokratie haben, sondern eher das Gegenteil davon. Also schon Diktaturen, teilweise Militärdiktaturen, und die diese Software also gezielt kaufen, um unter anderem Journalisten auszuspähen, die über dieses Land berichten wollen, die Oppositionelle ausspähen, die vielleicht daran interessiert sind, mal Wahlen einzuführen im Land. Also schon etwas, was moralisch eigentlich auf gar keinen Fall vertretbar ist.
Okay, Lanimu, du hattest noch irgendwie zur Hintergrundgeschichte dieser Firma noch was, was du sagen wolltest? Naja, das ist halt ganz spannend, wenn man sich das anguckt. Also wie du gerade sagtest, Hacking Team, das klingt irgendwie erstmal ein bisschen sperrig. Wie kommt man da überhaupt zu? Und Andreas hat ja gerade schon ausgeführt, das ist normalerweise, hast du in solchen Firmen sowas wie Auditing oder Pentest. Das heißt, du gehst dahin, um Firmen quasi zu schützen. Du untersuchst sie quasi, ob sie sicher sind, sind sie meistens nicht. Und dann sagst du ihnen, was sie besser machen sollen. So weit so legitim. Allerdings hat diese Firma praktisch, also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, vom ersten Tag an im Prinzip zwei Geschäftsfelder gehabt. Nämlich die Leute, die diese Firma aufgemacht haben, die haben früher ein sehr populäres Tool namens Evercap geschrieben. Damit, das ist so ein klassisches Dual-Use-Tool. Das heißt, man kann es irgendwie... Okay, was heißt klassisches Dual-Use-Tool? Genau, da komm ich jetzt gerade zu. Also Dual-Use hörst du immer dann, wenn du ein Programm hast, dass du als z.B. Systemadministrator oder als jemand, der der Firma oder der Organisation positiv zugetan ist, dein Netz irgendwie schützen kannst. Kannst du aber genauso gut auch einsetzen, um eben böswillige Dinge zu tun von außerhalb. Und dass da quasi die Technologie im Prinzip neutral ist, die unterscheidet halt nicht zwischen, wer benutzt mich jetzt. So und die haben eben dieses Tool geschrieben. Und dann kam wohl eine Anfrage von italienischen Polizei, die halt so sagten, ja hier tolles Tool. Also da ging es halt darum, Netzwerkverkehr abhören zu können. Das war so ein schönes modulares Toolkit. Und die sagten, ja das wäre ganz toll, wenn so einer dieser Module zufällig in der Lage wäre, Skype-Gespräche abzuhören. Und so soll das wohl gekommen sein. Dass die dann diese Firma sozusagen aufgemacht haben. Also wir haben eine italienische Firma, die sich sehr gut auskennt. Also ich mein, dieses Tool ist ja sozusagen relativ weit verbreitet, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Und sozusagen solide auch programmiert. Also die können schon was.
Jaja, kann man sagen.
Also die können was und die haben das eingesetzt, um in andere Leute Rechner einzubrechen. Ja, um das nochmal ganz klar zu sagen, es geht nicht nur um Rechner, es geht tatsächlich darum, alles, was du heutzutage an elektronischen Geräten dabei hast, sei es jetzt alle Arten von Mobiltelefonen gehören da zum Beispiel dazu. Das muss man sich halt auch ganz klar machen. Es geht nicht nur um Rechner, sondern im Prinzip alles, was so ein irgendwie ein Betriebssystem drauf hat und was man irgendwie sinnvoll abhören kann. Mit Gewinn und sage im Auftrag von Regierungen, die auch einen zweifelhaften Ruf haben. Wie das von Schatten geht und wieder der Hack vielleicht auch passiert, das können wir gleich noch klären. Wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten, wir werden auch im Verkehr. Danach geht's hier weiter im Chaosradio im Blumen auf Fritz.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft ermittelt gegen zwei Journalisten wegen Landesverrats. Sie hatten im Blog netzpolitik.org Informationen und Dokumente des Verfassungsschutzes veröffentlicht, die teilweise als geheim eingestuft waren. In den Artikeln ging es um eine Ausweitung der Internetüberwachung in sozialen Netzwerken. Einer der Beschuldigten ist der Gründer des Blogs Becke Dahl. Er sagte Fritz, es sei richtig gewesen, die Dokumente online zu stellen. Google weigert sich, Suchergebnisse auf Wunsch einzelner EU-Staaten weltweit zu löschen. Die französische Datenschutzaufsicht wollte das. Google sagt aber, kein Land habe das Recht zu bestimmen, welche Inhalte in einem anderen Land aufgerufen werden können. Der Europäische Gerichtshof hatte im vorletzten Monat entschieden, dass Google bestimmte Informationen über Privatpersonen, z.B. in der französischen oder der deutschen Google-Version, löschen muss, wenn sie belanglos oder veraltet sind. In der internationalen Google-Version sind sie aber weiterhin zu sehen. Im Indischen Ozean suchen Hubschrauber gerade nach weiteren möglichen Wrackteilen der seit über einem Jahr verschwundenen Boeing 777. An der zu Frankreich gehörenden Insel La Réunion war erst ein Flugzeugteil angeschwemmt worden und dann noch ein Teil eines Koffers. Experten halten es für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass beides von der malaysischen Passagiermaschine stammt. Klarheit soll eine genaue Untersuchung des Flugzeugteils bringen. Dazu wird das Teil Ende der Woche nach Toulouse gebracht. Die Brandenburger Polizei ist ab sofort bei Facebook unterwegs. Damit will sie vor allem die unter 30-Jährigen besser erreichen. Der Facebook-Account wird ab sofort 24 Stunden am Tag betrieben. Nach Hilfe hat sich die Brandenburger Polizei bei ihren Berliner Kollegen geholt. Die Berliner Polizei ist schon länger bei Facebook dabei, und hat auch ein Twitter-Profil. Das soll die Brandenburger Polizei im Herbst bekommen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Müggelheim haben wir 13 Grad und im Kreuzberg 15 Grad. Potsdam und Rheinsberg melden 14 Grad, und Cottbus und Bad Freienwalde 15 Grad. In den nächsten Stunden verziehen sich die meisten Wolken. Regen soll es kaum geben. In der Nacht kühlt es sich dann hier und da bis auf 8 Grad ab. Morgen viel Sonne, vor allem im Süden, dazu Höchstwerte bis 22 Grad. Und auch das Wochenende über geht es freundlich weiter. Es wird auch wieder wärmer. Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der A111 der Stadt Autobahn. Statt einwärts ist der Tunnel Ortskern Tegel im Moment komplett gesperrt, da wird die Fahrbahn neu gemacht. In Tegel gibt es Probleme auf der Gorki-Straße, im Bereich Bullestraße, da gehen die S-Bahnschranken nicht mehr hoch. Und auch mehrere BVG-Buslinien müssen umgeleitet werden. In Brandenburg gibt es Probleme auf der A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Lenin und Netzen wird gebaut, und da gibt es im Moment nur eine freie Spur. Und auch auf der A10, dem östlichen Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Spreeau gibt es Probleme. Da ist zwischen Rüdersdorf und Erkner nur die linke Spur frei. Noch eine Meldung von der S-Bahn. Wegen eines Polizeieinsatzes in Birkenwerde müsst ihr auf den Linien S1 und S8 im Moment mit Verspätungen und Ausfällen rechnen. Bloß geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr Fritz für die Hosentasche wollt, mit Livestream, Studio Message, Podcasts und jede Menge mehr, dann holt euch doch die Fritz App. Kostenlos und werbefrei in eurem App oder Play Store.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Chaos Radio im Blumen der Sendung, wo Leute vom Chaos Computer Club hier sind und über Dinge reden, die hackern so passieren. Heute geht es um Hacks und die Auswirkungen und Konsequenzen darüber. Mit Andreas Bog. Hallo und guten Abend. Hallo. Mit Danimo. Hallo und guten Abend. Guten Abend. Und zugeschaltet aus dem Fernberlin mit Erdgeist. Hallo und guten Abend.
Wunderschön, guten Abend.
Hört sich das nicht großartig an? Die Wunder der Technik. Es ist unglaublich. So, wir reden heute über das Hacking Team und haben schon festgestellt, also wir reden heute über Sicherheitslücken und Leute, die in anderer Leute Kommunikation einbrechen und was die Konsequenzen für Hacker und Leute, die programmieren sind, programmieren können, sein könnten. Wir haben über das Hacking Team geredet als Beispiel, haben festgestellt, dass es eine italienische Sicherheitsfirma ihr Wissen ausgenutzt hat, um das Regierung zu verkaufen und nicht nur irgendwelche Regierungen, sondern auch Regierungen, Regierungen, die einen, wie habt ihr es genannt, zweifelhaften Ruf haben, also Regimes und Diktaturen und sowas. Das alles rausgekommen ist bei einem Hack. Ich würde jetzt noch mal gerne wissen, wir haben schon gesagt, also ihr habt schon erzählt, die brechen halt irgendwie ein, was genau die da als Produkt verkauft haben, ob da auch wie was rausgekommen ist, also welche Art von Software, was genau haben die da gemacht, ob man das irgendwie mal kurz erklären kann. Kann der Erdgeist das vielleicht sagen?
Also generell waren natürlich mobile Endgeräte besonders im Ziel. Es ist also viel Software in Einsatz gekommen, was sich auf ja Mobiltelefon einhacken und dort auch Reboot fest, also beim nächsten Einschalten soll das möglichst immer noch da sein. Und du brauchst natürlich, um diese Software dazu installieren, bestimmte Vorfeldprogramme, die möglichst überall problemlos laufen sollen. Und mir ist dabei aufgefallen, dass auch Software, die ich mit programmiert habe, dabei eingesetzt worden ist. Ich habe da an so eine Bibliotheke mit programmiert, die gerade dafür da ist, ganz kleine Bineries zu basteln, also was man auf Mobiltelefon ganz gut gebrauchen kann. Und diese Bibliothek ist dann am Ende auch dort in den Repositories, also in den Softwarearchiven dieser Firma wieder gefunden worden. Fand ich persönlich dann mal diesen Blick auf die Situation, wenn man dann plötzlich selber betroffen ist und sich nicht wirklich dagegen wehren kann, fand ich schon spannend.
Okay, das ist der Punkt zu sagen, man ist dann auf einmal selber beteiligt, obwohl man das eigentlich gar nicht so geplant hat.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir noch ein bisschen anschaulicher erklären, was da eigentlich, also wie das funktioniert, was da passiert, wie das Vorgehen ist und wie die Software funktioniert. In der Regel ist es so, dass Computer und Mobiltelefone Sicherheitslücken haben. Das heißt, es werden Dateien geladen und dann passieren komische Dinge, weil die Datei ein komisches Format hat und plötzlich wird ein Programm des Angreifers ausgeführt. Also im Falle von Hacking Team war Flash einer der wichtigsten Vektoren. Flash, ein Programm, das man früher verwendet hat, um im Webvideos abzuspielen. Einige Seiten tun das immer noch. Und das passiert dann, dass man eine Mail bekommt, wo drin steht, hey, kuck mal, ich hab hier ein total tolles Video gesehen, ist ja großartig, lachste bestimmt total. In der Regel ist so eine E-Mail gut gemacht, kommt von jemanden, der, also sieht so aus, als würde sie von jemanden kommen, den man auch kennt. Also man hat Grund, da wirklich drauf zu klicken und dann poppt auch wirklich ein lustiges oder weniger lustiges, auf jeden Fall poppt ein Video hoch, das dann da läuft. Und während dieses Video läuft, wird im Hintergrund eine Software installiert, die dem Angreifer Zugriff auf den Rechner gibt. Das heißt, der kann sich angucken, was auf dem Desktop angezeigt wird. Der kann Dateien durchsuchen und runterladen, kann auch Dateien hochladen, Tastatureingaben mitverfolgen und so weiter und so fort. Also im Prinzip all das, was derjenige, der voll im Rechner oder voll im Telefon sitzt, auch kann, nur unauffällig und aus der Ferne.
Und das Ganze ist natürlich auch wieder auf dem Baukastenprinzip basiert. Also wenn du jetzt eine Behörde, die berechtigt ist, so etwas einzusetzen, wie das Remote Control System, haben die das genannt, beim Hacking System, also dieser Software-Baukasten, dann kannst du dir quasi genau aussuchen, was habe ich für einen Angreifer? Was brauche ich, um bei diesem Angreifer einzusteigen? Du kannst dann bei diesen entsprechenden Firmen auch gleich den passenden Exploit kaufen, der dann dafür geeignet ist oder lizenzieren, wie auch immer. Und das ist also wirklich zielgerichtet und maßgeschneidert. Und der Punkt ist, und glaube das ist der Punkt, wo wir dann wieder zur Erdgeist zurückkommen, ist, so eine Software schreibt man nicht von Grund auf. Also es ist nicht so, wenn jetzt das Hacking Team sich sagt, okay, wir wollen jetzt bei dem und dem einbrechen, dass sie dann die komplette Software geschrieben haben, sondern wenn man programmiert, benutzt man sehr viel vorgefertigtes Zeug, kann man sagen. Also Bibliotheken heißt das dann. Und nicht nur.
Du hast ja diese Sicherheitslücken, die der Andreas erwähnt hat. Die werden ja auch irgendwann alt. Andere finden genau dieselben Sicherheitslücken raus. Und dann hast du plötzlich keinen Vektor mehr, um auf diesen Rechner draufzukommen. Also musst du rumgehen und weiter shoppen und dein Arsenal von Angriffswerkzeugen aktuell halten. Und deswegen müssen die auch durch die Gegend gehen und dann bei anderen Sicherheitsforschern schauen, ob die die verkaufen, solches Wissen, oder ob sie da selber in solche Grundlagenforschung investieren und sich da Programme angucken. Und da gibt es so immer einige Ziele, wie zum Beispiel Flash, die sind lohnenswerter, weil das noch überall installiert ist. Dann gibt es so Dinge, dass du ein Windows einfach so von ferne Hops nehmen kannst. Das ist dann so der goldene Bullet. Das findest du so einmal alle zehn Jahre vielleicht. Aber das ist so üblicherweise die Probleme, die so eine Firma hat, die das versucht, regelmäßig zu verkaufen.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist das Problem, warum du da jetzt eine Rolle spielst, nicht, dass du so eine Sicherheitslücke rausgefunden hast, sondern dass du einfach Software geschrieben hast, die man benutzen kann zum Programmieren. Und zwar um irgendwas zu programmieren.
Genau, das ist mein Problem, wo ich nicht mal die Möglichkeit hatte, dort die moralische Entscheidung zu treffen, ob ich mich daran beteiligen möchte oder nicht. Wie andere, die zum Beispiel solche Sicherheitslöten weiterverkaufen, sondern ja auch mein Beitrag wurde dann einfach genommen, weil sie den an der Stelle brauchten. Und das so ein, ja, gängiges Software ist.
Ich glaube, ich versuche gerade einen Vergleich zu finden, wie man das so in ganz Bremen hinkriegt. Ich glaube, das ist, man schreibt eine Melodie und dann kommen Nazis und singen damit ein Lied. Dann denkt man sich so, das will ich eigentlich nicht so richtig. Und das Problem ist tatsächlich, das gibt es nicht erst seit diesem Hacking-Team-Angriff, sondern das gab es schon früher. Und ich habe vor der Sendung noch einen anderen Hacker vom Chaos Computer gesprochen mit Thorsten. Der hatte sich Anfang des Jahres schon mal Gedanken drüber gemacht. Warum das? Das fand ich ganz spannend, weil so Hacking-Team, das hat man jetzt zumindest, wenn man sich für dieses Thema interessiert, hat man das da gehört und auch von der sehr Problematik gehört. Aber das Thema ist anscheinend schon älter. Und ich habe vorhin, wie gesagt, mit ihm geredet und wollte als erstes von ihm wissen, wie er denn überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen ist, sich diese Gedanken zu machen. Also was bei ihm der Anlass war?
Ja, der ganz konkrete Anlass war eine Meldung, dass die DARPA, so eine militärische Forschungseinrichtung in den USA angekündigt hat, dass sie da in Zukunft irgendwelche Waffensysteme auf Android Tablet Basis realisiert und da eben über Android Tablets was ich irgendwelche Raketen steuern möchte. Und das war halt so ein Punkt, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das kann einfach nicht wahr sein, dass so offensichtlich der freie Code, den Hacker produzieren, freie Betriebssysteme, ich meine Linux ist ein gutes Beispiel, da gibt es sehr viele Leute, die da Code zu beitragen. Und es kann halt einfach nicht sein, dass dieser Code von diesen Leuten plötzlich genutzt wird, um Waffensysteme damit zu steuern, um damit Leute zu töten. Da kam ich dann halt endgültig an diesen Punkt, wo ich mir gesagt habe, wir müssen mal was dagegen tun.
Warte mal, ich will kurz zum Verständnis sagen, also es geht nicht darum, dass irgendwelche Hacker Waffensteuerungscode gebaut haben, sondern es ist einfach so, wenn man eine Android Tablet benutzt, um eine Waffensteuerung zu bauen, dann benutzt man automatisch auch Open Source Code, der halt da irgendwie beigesteuert wurde, der halt irgendwie fürs Betriebssystem vielleicht benutzt wird und der ist dann aber sozusagen Teil dieses Waffensystems.
Ganz genau, in dem Fall ist es halt genauso, dass eben der Code von irgendwelchen ahnungslosen netten Leuten genutzt wird, um damit wirklich Leute zu töten. Und ich meine, diesen Gedanken, den tragen ja schon viele Leute mit sich schon auch eine ganze Zeit lang rum. Ich ja auch. Dass man eben selber Softwareprojekte entwickelt oder auch Hardwareprojekte entwickelt, die immer im Sinne von Dual-Use, was ja nun schon bekannt sein sollte, eben auch für negative Zwecke missbraucht werden können. Und bei Open-Force-Software ist es halt so, die sind halt im Internet, die kann man sich einfach nehmen, das merkt keiner. Die werden dann eben verwendet für irgendwelche anderen, für so Projekte vom Militär beispielsweise oder für eben militärische Forschung oder von irgendwelchen Nachrichtendiensten oder eben Firmen, die Überwachungssoftware bauen. Eben zum Beispiel solche Firmen wie Hacking Team oder Gamma, die halt Software herstellen, die geeignet sind, um Leute zu überwachen, die Rechner zu infiltrieren und ja.
Aber jetzt ist ja so, dass da kann man ja eigentlich schwierig was gegen machen, oder? Weil das Wesen von Open Source Software ist ja gerade, hier ist die Software erstellt ins Internet, jeder darf damit machen, was er will. Wenn er sie auch Open Source macht, ist ja meistens eine der Bedingungen, die man mit dranknüpft.
Wie kann man das ändern? Man kann es auch nicht kontrollieren, was mit der Software passiert. Aber man hat natürlich immer die Möglichkeit, die Software, wenn man sie veröffentlicht hat, dass man da noch bestimmte Bedingungen dranknüpft. Und das machen ja alle Leute schon. Da gibt es dann verschiedene Open Source Lizenzmodelle, die dann halt von dem Entwickler gewählt werden, was ihm halt am besten gefällt. Sehr populär ist halt GPL beispielsweise, die halt im Grunde vorsieht, dass man zwar dieses Open Source Projekt benutzen darf, aber wenn man das verwendet, dann muss man eben diesen Teil auch selber wieder unter einer Open Source Lizenz veröffentlichen und anderen die Quellen eben zugänglich machen. Und das ist schon eine sehr restriktive Lizenzform. Es gibt halt noch weniger restriktive BSD-Lizenz beispielsweise oder mach doch was du willst, Lizenz wie die Beerware-License. Viele Leute mit großen und kleinen Softwareprojekten einfach veröffentlichen und sagen mach damit was du möchtest. Und wenn du der Meinung bist, dass es dir was wert, dann gib mir doch einfach beim nächsten Kongress ein Bier aus. Und das sind ja schon Bedingungen für die Benutzung des Source-Quotes und diese Bedingungen sind ja auch wirksam. In den allermeisten Fällen, wenn eben irgendwie kommerzielle Unternehmen sich an Open-Source-Projekten bedienen und das Internet als kostenlosen Quell-Quote-Verteiler ansehen und sich eben überhaupt nicht um diese ganzen Bedingungen kümmern, dann gibt es ja schon Projekte und Organisationen, die sich auch darum kümmern, dass das dann straffrecht oder eben verfolgt wird und dass es dann auch entsprechende Abmahnverfahren gibt und so weiter, dass diese kommerziellen Nutzer dieses Quell-Quotes einfach auch merken, dass das so nicht geht, dass man jetzt mit offener Software einfach nicht machen kann.
Okay, das möchte ich auch noch mal ein bisschen kurz erklären. Also es ist halt so, diese offene Software sagt zwar, du darfst hier fast machen, was du willst. Du musst nur, keine Ahnung, zum Beispiel dieselbe Lizenz drauf tun. Das klingt immer alles so locker. Das hat aber eine juristische Konsequenz. Das heißt, wenn jemand zum Beispiel diese Software nimmt, die sagt, du darfst nur die mitverwenden, wenn du sie unter der selben Lizenz veröffentlicht und man macht das nicht, dann kann man, wenn man die Leute dabei erwischt, das ist ja manchmal ein Problem, durchaus juristisch dagegen vorgehen und dann die auf Schalke zur Zeit fragen.
Das passiert auch, recht erfolgreich. Und die Idee war jetzt einfach, wenn man, ich zum Beispiel habe überhaupt gar kein Problem, wenn meine Softwareprojekte oder Hardwareprojekte, die ich so veröffentlicht habe, wenn die auch kommerziell genutzt werden. Aber ich habe ein Problem damit, wenn die zum Beispiel von Militär genutzt werden oder wenn irgendwelche Firmen wie Hacking Team oder so ankommen und einfach meinen Code kopieren und das in ihre Produkte integrieren. Und da war halt die Idee und das geisterte schon lange Zeit in der Szene so ein bisschen rum, dass man da ja mal was machen müsste. Und als eben diese Meldung rauskam, dass die DARPA das mit diesen Android Tablets da vorhat, dann dachte ich mir, ach, ich mach da jetzt einfach mal einen Vorschlag. Das hatte ich dann am Anfang des Jahres mal gemacht. Ich hab dann mit ein paar Leuten drüber gesprochen und hab einfach mal versucht, so eine kleine Klausel als Ergänzung zu allen möglichen bestehenden Open Source Lizenzen zu verfassen, die eben auch Bestand hat, wenn es eben darum geht, das mal vor Gericht auch zu klären. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn ich meine Software release und sage, ich möchte da jetzt meine Non-Military und Non-Intelligence-Klausel mit ranhängen und dann macht es aber trotzdem irgendeine Firma und das wird dann vielleicht auch noch benutzt vom sagen wir BKA und dann werden die dabei erwischt, dann möchte ich die Möglichkeit haben, ich lebe ja in einem Rechtsstaat und möchte die Möglichkeit haben, diese Firma zu verklagen und möglicherweise auch die Nutzer dieser Software, die das vielleicht auch wissentlich in Kauf nehmen, dass der Zulieferer dagegen Urheberrechte verstößt und dann möchte ich das Ganze von einem Gericht geklärt wissen, dass da eben Unrecht passiert oder eben nicht.
Das heißt also, die, nun das mal für Stellen in Frage, man geht nicht davon auf, dass man diese schadhafte Nutzung jeweils perfekt unterbinden kann, was man damit erreichen will, ist aber, dass man im Nachhinein was in der Hand habe, was man so hat, um den Leuten noch eins reinzuwirken.
Ganz genau. Ich möchte, dass sich ein Richter hinstellt und sagt, ja, du hast recht, die Firma muss jetzt hier ein Bußgeld bezahlen und die Firma muss jetzt zum Beispiel die Quellen ihres Staatstojaners offenlegen. In diesem Vorschlag, den ich da gemacht habe, steht das halt so im Grunde genommen drin, dass wenn jemand gegen diese Klausel verstößt, muss ja eben dieses Modul oder dieses Softwareprodukt, das er da vertreibt, auch offen liegen. Und dann muss sich halt ein Richter mal hinstellen und sagen, nö, da ist das nationale Interesse vielleicht irgendwie höher und du wirst jetzt in diesem Fall enteignet, was deine Urheberrechte angeht. Also dann soll halt erstmal jemand sagen, dass es keinen Bestand hat, dass ich meine Software, meine Veröffentlichung mit einer verbundenen Bedingung verknüpft habe. Also ich gehe natürlich nicht davon aus, dass das böse Firmen davon abhält, diesen Code zu verwenden. Aber sie werden mal darüber nachdenken. Ja, wenn es vielleicht doch irgendwie eine Rechtsabteilung gibt in dem entsprechenden Unternehmen, dann werden die möglicherweise davon abraten. Dann habe ich natürlich gewonnen. Aber ich hoffe halt auch, dass ich dadurch gewonnen habe, dass ich, oder dass halt ein Entwickler, der dann das auch verfolgt, mit einem öffentlichen Gerichtsprozess natürlich auch eine gewisse Öffentlichkeit schafft. Und das ist halt das, was wir halt brauchen. Wir brauchen dann eben so eine Diskussion. Und diese Diskussion kann nur stattfinden, wenn es eben so ein Gericht gibt, was so einen Fall mal verfolgt. Und das kann dann halt durch die, was ich, Organisationen wie zum Beispiel den CCC einfach auch öffentlich begleitet werden. Und wenn das dann da eben auch ein mediales Interesse dran gibt, dann ist das ja eigentlich eine ganz gute Sache. Und das war halt so die ganze Idee dahinter, dass man eine Diskussion anzetteln kann und führen kann in der Öffentlichkeit.
Thorsten Schröder war das Sicherheitsforscher und selber Chaos Computer Club Mitglied. Und es ging darum, wie man verhindern kann, dass der eigene Code, den man geschrieben hat und einfach der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellt, benutzt wird von den Bösen, sag ich mal. Und jemand, dem das passiert ist, ist halt zum Beispiel Erdgeist. Der hat auch bei uns gerade zugeschaltet ist. Und der ist, beim Hacking Team hat er quasi seinen eigenen Code entdeckt. Und Erdgeist, die, die, also was Thorsten jetzt gesagt hat, ist ja, naja, vor allen Dingen Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Ist das wirklich das Einzige, oder ist das, hat man tatsächlich irgendwie auch was Juristisches in der Hand, was man damit machen kann?
Na ich würde es erstmal total gerne teuer machen, dass ich sage, alle Open-Source-Projekte, die wollen, können es einfach für umsonst benutzen. Und wenn jemand das im Militär- und nachrichtendienstlichen Bereich einsetzen will, dann habe ich erstmal was dagegen. Aber man kann dafür so siebenstellige Beträge gerne eine Lizenz dazukaufen. Und wenn es dann im Nachhinein herauskommt, dann kann man gleich sagen, dass das Geld an WikiLeaks oder ähnliche Organisationen gleich kanalisiert wird, sodass jeder Geheimdienst, der diese Software einsetzt, dann auch noch gleich eine gute Sache spendet. Und ich glaube, das ist realistisch, dass man das dann zivilrechtlich da durchfechten kann.
Aber macht man sich da nicht quasi mitschuldig? Was im Prinzip dann passiert, ist ja, man setzt eine Summe an. Man sagt, du darfst mal eine Software für Tötungsmaschinen verwenden, wenn du so und so viel Geld bezahlst.
Na verhindern kann man es ja nicht, wie wir es gesehen haben. Es ist ja immer erst nachträglich, wenn es herauskommt. Man kann es ja erst mal verbieten und für den Fall, dass es trotzdem gemacht wird, dann eine Summe heranschreiben. Was soll man sonst auch tun?
Das ist dann im Prinzip Realpolitik.
Das ist Realpolitik und hat dann wenigstens einen durchsetzbaren Aspekt mit dabei. Während ich denke, dass ein einfaches Verbot ohne Sanktionsandrohung dann am Ende nicht wirklich zu irgendwelchen Ergebnissen führt. Aber wenn man dann zivilrechtlich wenigstens dann noch die Möglichkeit hat, dort Geld für einen guten Zweck da rauszupressen, dann denke ich, dass das dann schon irgendwie noch eher in die richtige Richtung geht, als am Ende mit die Fäuste zu beilen und sagen du, du hättest es nicht machen dürfen, weil ich hab's dir verboten. Dann erntest du meistens so ein müdes Lächeln und die machen trotzdem was sie wollen.
Wie ist das denn eigentlich? Um sowas durchzusetzen bräuchte es dann tatsächlich diese Gerichtsbarkeit und das heißt ja wiederum auch, dass so eine Lizenz, die man an seine Software dran klebt, irgendwie so formuliert werden müsste, dass sie international funktioniert. Wie ist denn da, gibt es da heute schon Erfahrungen, gibt es da schon diese Lizenzen, die an Software dran sind, wie das überhaupt ist? Also gibt es da nicht irgendwie Rechtstreitigkeiten, dass man über jeden einzelnen Buchstaben diskutiert?
Also die Creative Commons und die GPL sind eigentlich inzwischen fast weltweit jeweils ein nationales Recht interpretiert worden und ich glaube nicht, dass da so eine einfache Klausel die militärische und geheimdienstliche Nutzung ausschließt, dass die, wenn die so deutlich formuliert ist, nicht auch in jeder Juristdiktion interpretierbar wäre.
Man müsste gerade bei der GPL halt nochmal schauen, weil da ja Einschränkungen immer schwierig sind, aber bei den anderen Lizenzen sehe ich das relativ und ich halte da Einschränkungen schwierig. Na, die GPL ist eigentlich darauf ausgelegt, dass du eben keine Einschränkungen machen darfst. Das ist immer die Frage, was ist Freiheit? Es ist Freiheit, möglichst alles damit tun zu dürfen. Wenn du das so siehst und die GPL sieht das so, dann wäre quasi zu sagen, ich verkaufe hier nicht an den militärischen oder Geheimdienstkomplex. Das wäre halt eine unzulässige Einschränkung der Lizenz. Das heißt, diese beiden Dinge zu kombinieren ist schwierig. Es gibt andere Lizenzen, da ist das ganz einfach. Einfach nur, wie Erdgeist sagte. Quasi ein weiterer Absatz bei der GPL im Speziellen und den GPL-Verwandten Lizenzen. Stell ich mir das etwas schwieriger vor. Okay, das ist also die juristische Frage. Das heißt also auch, da könnte man nicht als Hacker sich hinsetzen und sagen, okay, ich schreibe einfach noch einen Satz in die Lizenz. Das müssten wahrscheinlich schon Rechtsanwälte machen. Wie lange dauert sowas? Also wie lange hat so eine Creative Commons Lizenz zu entwickeln gedauert?
Das hat sich jetzt über die letzten zehn Jahre, glaube ich, rausentwickelt. Und jetzt sind es dann das erste Mal die Verfahren da auch zu Ende geführt.
Ja, und da war halt auch mindestens ein Rechtsprofessor aus den USA Vollzeit dran beteiligt und wir sind jetzt bei Version 5. Also da gibt es tatsächlich Versionen von, ich weiß nicht, bei Version 4 oder 5 irgendwie sowas von, also das ist das ist schon nicht ganz ohne und bei Creative Commons ist es auch so, dass man sich versucht hat an die jeweiligen Landesrechte anzupassen, um eben nicht so sehr der Interpretation ausgeliefert zu sein. Aber letztendlich, letztendlich ja, bei vielen Lizenzen könnte man wahrscheinlich erstmal einfach was dran schreiben. Schön wär's natürlich, wenn das ein koordinierter Effort wäre. Also eine gemeinsame Anstrengung, wo auch mal ein paar Rechtsanwälte aus verschiedenen Jurisdiktionen drüber geguckt haben. Die andere spannende Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist die, man sagt jetzt einfach so, ich möchte nicht, dass die Bösen das nutzen. Jetzt ist es ja nicht so einfach. Ja, wer ist denn böse? Ja genau, wer ist böse? Und was ist böse? Wo würde man denn dann die Grenze ziehen? Also da würde ich mir fast schon wieder denken, da gibt's dann schon alleine bei den hier Anwesenden wahrscheinlich drei verschiedene Meinungen.
Ich glaube, Militär und Geheimdienste kann man da erst mal reinschreiben. Ich glaube, da gibt's einen Konsens in weiten Teilen der Hacker-Community, dass das erstmal so ist. Und dass wir irgendwie nicht bei Skynet mitmachen wollen, ist ja auch klar. Es gibt ja da immer so diese Zeilen, die man ganz am Anfang seines Codes hinschreiben soll. Wenn ich Teil von Skynet bin, dann beende dich mal sofort.
Okay, naja, aber also irgendwie Geheimdienste. Also ich finde, selbst da könnte man diskutieren und sagen, naja, aber wenn manche Geheimdienste tatsächlich daran arbeiten, Terroranschläge zu verhindern, sollen sie dann nicht vielleicht die Software benutzen dürfen, aber okay. Oder du nimmst es noch viel radikaler und sagst einfach, naja, Geheimdienste steht so in der Verfassung, wenn wir das haben wollen, dann sollen wir gefälligst in den Gesetzen die Gesetze umstricken und nicht versuchen, das andersrum zu machen. Das verstehe ich nicht. Naja, sagst du, wir bekämpfen das jetzt über Lizenzen? Im Einzelfall? Darüber wollen wir heute reden. Ich würde jetzt sagen, nicht die Sendung umleiten wollen in Schaffen wir jetzt Geheimdienste ab oder nicht? Nein, nein, aber das ist aber die Diskussion, die du dann führen kannst. Ich wollte nur Liz Teufels Advokat spielen. Das macht an der Stelle keinen Sinn. Was ich fragen wollte, ist ja, bei Geheimdiensten kann ich mir das vorstellen, dass tatsächlich alle Hacker sagen, so eine Geheimdienste grundsätzlich nicht. Aber bei Militär ist es tatsächlich so eine Sache. Die machen ja tatsächlich auch Einsätze, die helfen. Und dazu werden sicherlich auch Software benutzt. Und dann ist ja die Frage, will man es wirklich dem Militär direkt verbieten? Oder will man es der ganzen Polizei verbieten? Ist das wirklich so klar zu sagen? Also stellt man sich da nicht in die Ecke, wo man sagt, hm, schwierig?
Das muss man, glaube ich, am Ende auch mit sich selbst ausmachen. Ich erinnere mich, als mein Sohn noch ziemlich klein war und ich glaube, wir guckten Star Wars. Dann meinte er, da gewinnen ja auch immer die Guten gegen die Bösen. Und fragten wir ihn ja, woran erkennst du denn, wer gut und wer böse ist? Da dachte er kurz nach und meinte irgendwie, naja, es hängt schon davon ab, auf welcher Seite man steht, oder? Und so ein bisschen sich das auch so. Leider ist es auch nicht so, dass die Hacker-Community geschlossen Geheimdienste und Militärs ablehnt. Es gibt da durchaus eine Fraktion, die ist in den USA stärker. Da ist offensichtlich die Kontaktangst nicht so ausgeprägt. Die sagt, entweder ist mir völlig egal. Hauptsache, ich kriege Spielzeug. Oder sagt, ich bin stramer Patriot und selbstverständlich werde ich gegen den islamischen Terror auch mal meine O-Dates-Instellungen bringen. Das kommt leider durchaus vor.
Dann muss quasi jeder für sich eine eigene Formulierung finden, die würde man so machen.
Ich denke, dass keine Militärs, keine Geheimdienste, das ist einfach entscheidbar und etwas, worauf sich auch viele einigen können. Man kann das wie bei Creative Commons machen, dass es verschiedene Abstufungen gibt.
Die Radikalität ist dann keine Militär, keine Geheimdienste, keine Polizei und dann stuft man es runter oder wie?
Weiß ich nicht. Kann mir gerade so als Idee. Mit kleinen Icons. Schlagstock, Panzer, Schlapphut.
Ich glaube wir müssen das gleich noch mal im Detail ausdiskutieren. Zwei Sprechstunden. Ja, herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaosradio in Blue Moon hier auf Fritz. Wir sprechen heute unter anderem darüber, was passiert, wenn man selber Dinge programmiert und die dann von den bösen Leuten mitverwendet werden. Und dazu begrüße ich ganz recht herzlich Andreas Bog, hallo und guten Abend. Und Danimo, hallo und guten Abend. Hallo. Und Erdgeister, hallo und guten Abend. Und wir haben in der letzten halben Stunde von der Firma Hacking Team geredet und eine Firma, die unter anderem Regime und Diktaturen dabei unterstützt hat, Leute technologisch anzugreifen und dazu eigene Software programmiert hat, aber dazu auch Software von anderen Leuten programmiert hat, die andere Leute programmiert haben, zum Beispiel von Erdgeist. Und da so eine Software häufig ins Netz gestellt wird und mit so einer Lizenz ihr sagt, naja, im Prinzip dürfen die alle verwenden, wenn ihr diese paar Dinge beachtet, gibt es jetzt die Idee, ja, wir könnten das irgendwie einschränken, dass für bestimmte Zwecke darf die nicht benutzt werden. Wenn man das doch macht, muss man das irgendwie teuer bezahlen. Und dann war bei mir so die Frage, wie macht man das denn, was genau verbietet man denn, wo zieht man da die Grenze? Und jetzt wurde hier so gesagt, naja, vielleicht kann man das wirklich einfach sagen, nicht militär, nicht Geheimdienste. Ich finde aber, es ist ein bisschen unklar, deswegen würde ich jetzt gerne alle drei Leute noch mal fragen wollen einzeln, was sie konkret bei sich reinschreiben würden, an ihre Software, wie die in Zukunft verwendet werden darf. Erdgeist macht den Anfang. Also was würdest du jetzt sagen, wer darf das nicht benutzen oder was darf damit nicht gemacht werden?
Also ich würde sagen, ich würde ein Nutzungsverbot für militär Geheimdienste und auf Computern von Menschen, die dem einfach nicht zugestimmt haben, dass diese Software da ausgeführt wird, sodass schon das Aue einbringen in Computer oder Mobiltelefone oder vielleicht wenn es am Ende auch plötzlich Hörgeräte oder irgendwie Implantate sind. Das ist ja eine ganze Dimension, wo ich ganz gewiss nicht möchte, dass meine Software gegen den Willen desjenigen, der die Hardware durch die Gegend trägt, auch eingesetzt wird.
Der Jurist, der mir sagt jetzt sofort, also gegen den Willen ist ja nicht dasselbe wie gegen die Kenntnis. Also zum Beispiel beim Hörgerät wird ja wahrscheinlich ein User gar nicht irgendwie explizit das überhaupt erfassen, was für Software draufläuft.
Der denkt sich aber auch schon, dass da nur Software drauf ist, die schon von, keine Ahnung, seinem Arzt oder den jeweiligen Programmierern der Firma dort für sinnvoll erachtet worden ist. Und wenn jemand nachträglich dort was installiert zum Abschnorcheln, dann ist das wohl deutlich gegen den Willen des Benutzers. Ich denke, da muss dein Hobbyjurist jetzt nicht im Vorfeld darüber streiten.
Na gut, aber wäre vielleicht auch mal eine interessante Option. Dani Mo, was würdest du reinschreiben bei deiner Software? Ich bin da ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz mit mir selber im Reinen bei dieser ganzen Geschichte, weil, also klar, ich könnte mir irgendwie schon vorstellen, so was da reinzuschreiben. Ich mache meistens GPL-Software. Ich habe schon erklärt, wo die juristischen Hürden da liegen. Aber jetzt rein so von dem, was ich denke, was sinnvoll wäre. So eine Abstufung, auch wenn ich es dem Andreas jetzt wegnehme, wie Andreas das vorgeschlagen hat, klingt erst mal wie ein sehr sinnvoller Ansatz. Also zu sagen, je nachdem, was jemand mit seinem Gewissen vereinbaren kann, wenn du mich jetzt fragst, welche dieser Abstufungen ich persönlich nehmen würde. Darum geht es genau. Na gut, dann werde ich mal Farbe bekennen. Ich würde wahrscheinlich dann tatsächlich die maximale Ausbaustufe nehmen wollen. Also keine Geheimdienste, kein Militär, keine Polizei.
Ja.
Das ist interessant. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute nicht anfragen können. Und wenn die Polizei mir einen Grund nennt für ein spezielles Projekt, das ist ja bei Creative Commons auch so. Da steht irgendwie Non-Commercial News, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es nicht kommerziell verwenden ist, sondern dass die Leute erst mal bei mir anzutanzen haben und mir erklären müssen, warum ich das total cool finden soll, dass sie meine Software in genau diesem Projekt hier zu verwenden sollen. Und wenn das jetzt irgendwie für einen Search-and-Rescue-Helikopter ist, der irgendwie garantiert nichts anderes machen kann als Search-and-Rescue, dann ist das völlig okay für mich.
Ich finde die Frage schwierig. Und zwar insbesondere deswegen, weil das ist ein ähnliches Ding wie die GPL versus BSD-License-Debatte, wo wenn man sagt, naja, eigentlich glaubt man an Urheberrechte ja sowieso nicht so richtig, dann plötzlich aber anfängt, mithilfe von Urheberrechten Dinge durchzusetzen, das ist halt schon Widerspruch. Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich nicht einfach weiter an bestimmte Software irgendwie heranschreibe hier, all rights reversed, mach doch was ihr wollt damit. Auf der anderen Seite kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass ich nicht will, dass mit meiner Software, keine Ahnung, Bomben gebaut werden, Leute erschossen werden und es ist, glaube ich, eine Einzelfallentscheidung. Und dann müssen wir erstmal gucken, was es gibt.
Wie pro Software meinst du?
Ja, schon pro Software.
Aber wäre dann nicht mein Vorschlag letztendlich auch zielführend dafür? Abgesehen davon, dass du dich nicht vielleicht mit jeder Anfrage auseinandersetzen magst.
Ja, nee, die fragen mich im Zweifelsfall gar nicht. Also da kommt so ein bisschen das philosophische Problem rein.
Naja, wir machen das ja alles. Also zumindest, ich habe jetzt mal eine Antwort unter der Promesse gegeben, dass das, was THS gerade in seinem Interview vorgeschlagen hat, das Ziel ist nämlich, dass man den Leuten wenigstens dann auf die Finger hauen kann, wenn es rauskommt. Es bleibt schwierig. Aber bei dieser ganzen Hacking-Nummer gab es da noch eine andere Sache. Und da gibt es schon ein Regelwerk, da wird vom sogenannten Wassenaher-Abkommen gesprochen. Was ist das und inwiefern kann das sowas regeln?
Das ist ein ganz spannender Punkt, weil eine weitere wichtige Komponente, außer in Anführungszeichen normalen Software-Komponenten, die in der Hacking-Team-Software und in anderen Spionage-Softwaren drin ist, ist ja der, wie komme ich in die Rechner rein? Also die sogenannten Exploits, die dafür sorgen, dass mein Angreifercode ausgeführt wird auf dem Zielsystem, dem Zielrechner, dem Zielmobiltelefon. Und da kommen die sogenannten All-Days ins Spiel. Das heißt, Sicherheitslücken, die unbekannt sind, Exploits dafür, möglicherweise auch Exploits für bekannte Sicherheitslücken.
Also dann muss man vielleicht noch dazu sagen, Exploits, das heißt, es gibt immer Sicherheitslücken, das heißt so eine theoretische Möglichkeit, wie man in ein System einbrechen kann. Und Exploits ist dann die konkrete praktische Umsetzung, die auch wirklich funktioniert.
Genau, und das Wassener Abkommen ist also ein Abkommen, das die Exportrestriktion für sogenannte Dual-Use-Goods regelt, also für Technologie, die möglicherweise auch zum Waffenbau verwendbar ist, aber nicht unbedingt verwendet werden muss. Da geht es erstmal klassischerweise um so Geschichten wie lange, zähe, hitzebeständige, innen besonders glatte Metallrohre, aka kann man auch eine Kanone draus bauen. Und in dieses Abkommen wurde jetzt aber aufgenommen, Software, die dazu geeignet ist, in anderer Leute Rechner einzubrechen. Also genau die Exploits, von denen wir reden, die integraler Bestandteil sind von solchen Angriffen. Und Hacking Team hat ziemlich interessant gezeigt, dass dieses Wassener Abkommen schwierig ist, weil einerseits klar, kann man es moralisch verstehen, man möchte eigentlich nicht, dass wenn es schon solche Firmen gibt, die Überwachungssoftware bauen und wenn wir vielleicht mal argumentieren, dass es auch legitime Einsatzzwecke dafür gibt, dann soll es trotzdem nicht den Bösen in die Hände fallen. Das versucht dieses Wassener Abkommen zu regeln, dass man halt einfach nicht in den Sudan exportieren darf oder wohin auch immer. Leider zeigen die E-Mails von Hacking Team sehr deutlich, wie wenig das funktioniert. Also da wird halt irgendeine Stromann-Firma dazwischen geschaltet und dann wird es über zwei, drei Stufen exportiert und dann kommt die Software auch schon da an, wo sie hin soll. Da reden die auch sehr, sehr offen drüber in diesen E-Mails. Man kann die sich angucken, wo Wikileaks sind hier veröffentlicht. Der Unterschied ist einfach zu klassischer Regelung von Militärtechnologie, dass man so ein Panzer durchaus sehen kann. Der nimmt Raum ein, da ist relativ leicht zu überwachen. Da gab es auch mal Fälle, wo ein Zollbeamter in Hamburg die Landwirtschaftsmaschinen sich mal näher angucken wollte und dann hatten die plötzlich Ketten und einen Kanonenrohr. Und dann ist halt der Export geplatzt. Das ist mit Software nicht so einfach, wie jeder weiß. So eine Micro SD-Card ist nicht besonders groß. Die ist schnell mal über Grenzen geschmuggelt. Übers Internet geht das auch wunderbar, ohne Spuren zu hinterlassen. Also der Wunsch ist verständlich, diese Technologie regeln zu wollen, sodass Bösen nicht verwenden. Das Problem ist, es scheitert halt völlig in der Praxis. Gerade ist also auch dieses Wassenaer-Abkommen deswegen ein bisschen in Verruf geraten, weil auch legitime Sicherheitsforscher unter den Effekten von Wassenaer leiden. Also die plötzlich keine Sicherheitslücken nicht mehr über Grenzen diskutieren können mit der Herstellerfirma, weil es ein verbotener Export ist.
Das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen nach Vorzeitspeicherung an. Die Ungefährlichsten müssen unter Leiden, die anderen, die umgehen es eh irgendwie. Ja, das hast du aber bei vielen gesetzlichen Regelungen, dass du immer einen kollateralen Schaden hast. In dem Fall geht es ja wirklich noch darum, dass jegliche Form von Exploit erst mal als böse angesehen wird. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel in, sagen wir mal, einem Produkt der Firmen, die jetzt auf deiner Seite des Teils leben, Microsoft, Google, you name it, dann kann ich nicht einfach zu denen hingehen und sagen, hier guckt mal, ich habe hier folgendes Beispiel dafür, dass euer Programm kaputt ist. Sondern in dem Fall liefere ich schon nach diesem Abkommen so gesehen eine Waffe oder ein Dual-Use-Gut. Das habe ich schon verstanden, aber das Problematische scheint zu sein, dass dieses Abkommen null dagegen hilft, dass solche Sachen irgendwie verhindert werden, aber es behindert halt, dass Leute sich drüber halten. Das heißt, diese Diskussion unter Forschern kommt dann zu mehr liegen oder gibt es dann irgendwie einen Umweg, wie man das trotzdem machen kann oder dass man dann rast und brennt?
Es gibt einen Umweg, also das ist alles noch nicht in trockenen Tüchern. Die Umsetzung nationaler Gesetze ist noch nicht fertig und deswegen ist es alles auch mit ein bisschen Vorsicht und Skepsis zu behandeln. Aber es gibt tatsächlich schon erste Forscher, die angefangen haben, Sicherheitslücken nicht mehr erstmal vertraulich an den Hersteller zu melden, sogenannte Responsible Disclosure. Also fangen wir vorne an, ich finde eine Sicherheitslücke in irgendeiner bekannten Software, sagen wir im Internet Explorer. Dann ist sozusagen der als moralisch vertretbar anerkannte Weg für alle Beteiligten, naja, man schreibt halt eine Mail an Microsoft und sagt, irgendwie passt mal auf, ihr habt da ein Problem, fix das doch mal. Und wenn man dann keine Antwort bekommt, dann schreibt man nach drei Monaten nochmal hin und sagt irgendwie, also wenn ihr jetzt nicht reagiert, dann veröffentliche ich das irgendwann. Und gibt damit dem Hersteller Zeit, die Sicherheitslücke sich anzugucken, zu fixen, einen Patch dafür zu schreiben, den Patch an seine Kunden zu schicken, sodass wenn die Information rauskommt über die Sicherheitslücke, eigentlich viele Benutzer der Software schon geschützt sind, so nennt er Responsible Disclosure. Ist aber halt nach Wassern an Export. Jetzt hat dieses Wassernabkommen eine Ausnahme, und zwar die Ausnahme existiert für quasi alles, was open source ist, alles was veröffentlicht ist und was zumindest ein Sicherheitsforscher, nämlich Stefan Esser, auch aus Deutschland getan hat, ist einfach sofort die komplette Information zu veröffentlichen. Was ein Vorgehen ist, dass man als Full Disclosure bezeichnet, hier so, hier Welt, hier ist die Sicherheitslücke, kommt damit klar. Hat den Vorteil, er hat damit nicht gegen Wassener verstoßen. Hat den eklatanten Nachteil, dass der Hersteller keine Zeit hat, darauf zu reagieren und einen Patch rauszubringen, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Leute geschützt sind. Man muss sagen, in dem konkreten Fall war das eine Sicherheitslücke, die jetzt nicht so furchtbar relevant ist. Es ging um eine Privilege Escalation auf OSX.
Eine was?
Eine Privilege Escalation.
Wenn du ein normaler Nutzer bist und Admin-Rechte bekommen möchtest, das ist eine Privilege Escalation. Das ist eine Situation. Also erstens gibt es solche Lücken in der Regel haufenweise. Und zweitens ist es auch noch nicht besonders gefährlich. Wenn ich erst mal Code ausgefüllt habe auf dem Rechner des Nutzers, gibt es immer Wege, irgendwas zu tun. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man dadurch aus der Ferne alle Macintoshes hacken kann oder so. Also eine vergleichsweise mittelinteressante Lücke. Und aber durchaus gemeint, die Debatte darüber anzuregen, was denn dieses Wassener Abkommen heißt und wie man mit Sicherheitslücken umgehen soll, was denn für die Gesellschaft der beste Weg ist, mit einer Sicherheitslücke umzugehen.
Und dann kommen wir an einen interessanten Punkt, dass man sich mal fragt, naja gut, aber es scheint ja doch kein so großes Problem zu sein, weil meine Güte, dann wird halt irgendwie die Sicherheitslücke veröffentlicht und dann patcht man da, gibt's ein Update und patcht man das. Ja, mein, entwegen gehen ein paar Rechnerhops, aber ganz so einfach ist es nicht, weil ja immer mehr Dinge ans Internet angeschlossen sind oder zumindest so digitalisiert werden, dass sie tatsächlich so Angriffsmöglichkeiten für so etwas bieten. Und dann kommen wir zu einer interessanten Geschichte, die auch die Tage rauszukommen ist, nämlich, dass man auch Autos mittlerweile hacken kann. Wie das genau geht, klären wir gleich vorher eine kleine Musik von Drake und The Zodiac Shadows. Shadow, Draco und the Zodiac hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz im Blumen. Und die Sendung ist mittlerweile schon an einem Punkt angekommen, wo ich sie nicht mehr einfach nur so kurz zusammenfassen kann. Aber wir können allgemein gesagt sprechen wir heute über Sicherheitslücken und den verantwortungsvollen Umgang damit bzw. wie man verhindern kann, dass die Bösen damit irgendwie so Unsinn treiben, also das möglichst verhindern kann. Und wir sind jetzt gerade ein Punkt angekommen, wo wir über sogenannte Zero Day Exploits auch reden. Also die Tatsache, wenn jemand eine Sicherheitslücke herausfindet, dann ist das Problem, wie schützt man die Leute am besten damit? Und dann gibt es verschiedene Arten und Möglichkeiten, wie man das macht. Man kann zum Beispiel erst mal dem Hersteller sagen, du Hersteller, da ist was so ein bisschen kaputt und möglicherweise sollst du das reparieren, bevor ich das an die Öffentlichkeit gebe. Aber dann gibt es andererseits wiederum das Problem, es gibt eine internationale Regelung, das Wassernahe Abkommen, das eigentlich dafür da ist, dass die Bösen nicht so eine Sicherheitslücke in die Hände kriegen. Aber dass dann, wenn jetzt ein Sicherheitsforscher in Deutschland einer Firma in den USA sagen will, du hast da ein Problem, dass das geht nicht, weil das nach dieser Regelung wiederum dann quasi schon ein Verkauf ist.
Aber war denn jetzt nicht auch schon der Hack von dem Hacking Team Verstoß gegen dieses Wassernahe Abkommen? Da sind ja auch ein paar Zero-Day-Exploits öffentlich geworden bei.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, haben die das sozusagen...
Wassernahe ist relativ neu, zumindest die Umsetzung nationaler Gesetze passiert ja gerade erst und die Lücken, die haben sie ja schon eine Weile rumzulegen.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, war es ja bei Hacking Team auch so, dass die sich durchaus so am klaren waren, dass die mit Diktaturen und Regimes, die eher so schmutzig sind, handeln und das dann über Zwischenfirmen gemacht haben. Eine andere interessante Sache war, dass sie wohl interessanterweise auch staatsnahe Fürsprecher hatten, die auch irgendwie so meinten, ja komm lass mal irgendwie 5° sein. Das ist Berichterstattung, die ich jetzt auch nur so gelesen und zur Kenntnis genommen habe, aber wenn die wirklich stimmt, dann wäre das natürlich auch noch mal eine ziemlich heiße Geschichte.
Also es kann sein, dass sie dagegen andere Embargobestimmungen verstoßen haben. Das ist nicht was in dem konkreten Fall, wo sie tatsächlich umgearbeitet haben.
Also jetzt sind ja die Zero Days nicht mehr Zero Days.
Ach so, du meinst, du meinst zu sagen, dass die Leute, die beim Hacking Team eingestiegen sind und diese Daten veröffentlicht haben? Also das ist übrigens noch ein anderer Satz an der Punkt, die, also weil wir gerade auch so ein bisschen über die Ethik des Hackens sprechen, ist denn der Einbruch beim Hacking Team eigentlich der Hackerethik zufolge ethisch richtiges Handeln eigentlich nicht, oder?
Puh, ist jetzt wie bei Star Wars, am Ende ist immer, wer du grad bist, kommt drauf an, wer die Guten sind. Und wenn man dann bei den Rebellen verhindert, dass der Todesstern da mit den armen Klonensoldaten da in die Luft gesprengt wird, dann ist es ja auch vielleicht ein erstrebenswertes Ziel.
Also ich halte es schon für gerechtfertigt. Also der Fall hat erstens dokumentiert, wie weit verbreitet tatsächlich die Zusammenarbeit mit Regimes ist, dass das Software zugeliefert wird, hat dokumentiert, wie der ganze O-Day-Markt funktioniert. Also muss man ja auch sagen, es gibt ja nicht nur die Varianten, ich veröffentliche die Sicherheitslücke oder ich sage dem Hersteller Bescheid, es gibt noch die Variante, von der reden wir hier. Ich verkaufe die auf dem grauen bis schwarzen Markt an jemanden, der damit irgendwo einbrechen möchte und sage dem Hersteller nicht Bescheid, sage der Öffentlichkeit nicht Bescheid.
Aber die interessante Sache ist halt sagen, man heißt sozusagen den Einbruch gut, also die Anwendung von Mitteln, die man normalerweise nicht gut heißt. Also das ist halt so ein bisschen, also klar, irgendwie man stellt sich hin und sagt so haha Hacking Team, die haben es verdient, aber man will eigentlich nicht, dass diese Mittel allgemein... Ich glaube, es geht gar nicht mal so um dieses ja ha, die haben es verdient, sondern es ist halt eine der wenigen Möglichkeiten, also korrigiere mich, falls ich irgendwas übersehe, überhaupt erst mal aufzuzeigen, was da eigentlich im Hintergrund alles abläuft.
Darf ich da kurz reingerätschen? Wir haben heute genau den Fall wieder.
Ich meine Landesverrat.
Hallo?
Ja, das ist es. Ich wäre jetzt auch fast drauf gekommen. Ja, letztendlich ist es eine ähnliche Geschichte. Aber es ist auch ein bisschen Selbstjustiz.
Die Blogger heute, die da oder die Blogger von Netzpolitik, also die Journalisten dort, haben auch dann im Rahmen des ihnen zugestandenen Impetos dann eben ihre Möglichkeiten benutzt und diese Dokumente veröffentlichen, weil sie gedacht haben, dass ein überwiegender Teil der Gesellschaft daran Interesse hat. Deswegen denke ich auch, dass es ein überwiegender Teil der Gesellschaft Interesse daran hat, zu gucken, was da wieder das Hacking Team sich geriert hat.
Aber da muss man schon eine Entscheidung machen, weil was Netzpolitik macht, ist ja über Dinge berichten, die ihnen von anderen Leuten zugetragen wurden. Also quasi wenn die über den Hacking Team Hack schreiben, das ist ja quasi deren Position. Na ja, da wollte ich gerade drauf kommen sozusagen. Und die haben diese Informationen ja von Leuten, die in dem Inneren der Ministerien gearbeitet haben und ihnen diese Informationen zugetragen haben. Da geht es also um Whistle Blower. Und die Leute, die beim Hacking Team eingebrochen sind, das ist tatsächlich, also was du jetzt sagen, schön euphemistisch, irgendwie Voss-Full Whistle Blowing, die sind ja von außen da eingebrochen. Und das ist ja der wichtige Unterschied. Es ist schon schwierig, oder?
Ich glaube, das muss dann am Ende nachträglich entschieden werden. Die Gesellschaft muss dort jetzt drauf gucken und für sich entscheiden, ob das okay war oder nicht. Und beim nächsten Mal wird es dann moralische Standards geben, die sich da jetzt an diesem Fall vielleicht entzündet haben. Also sprich, dass die dann mal ausformuliert werden, dass man darüber spricht. Und das kann natürlich immer nur an solchen Fällen passieren, wo man dann mal sieht, wie die genauen Folgen sind, wo man dann am plastischen Beispiel sieht, ob dort die Zivilgesellschaft am Ende einen Nettogewinn oder einen Nettoverlust rausgezogen hat.
Aber es ist komplizierter. Aber dann kommen wir jetzt doch noch zu dem Thema, was die Sicherheitslücken mittlerweile so anrichten können. Und sie können tatsächlich viel mehr machen, als nur da werden Rechner übernommen, da wird Kommunikation abgehört. Was natürlich an und für sich schon schlimm genug sein kann. Insbesondere wenn es darum geht, dass man vielleicht ein Oppositioneller in einem Regime ist und das Leib und Leben davon abhängen, dass Kommunikation nicht aufliegt. Aber es gibt auch andere Dinge, die die richtige Welt beeinflussen können. Und das ist zum Beispiel, dass Dinge gehackt werden und damit Unsinn getrieben wird, die Gebrauchsgegenstände sind mehr oder weniger, aber mittlerweile Internetanschluss haben. Oder zumindest ein oder mehrere Computer an Bord. Und eine so eine Sache ist, und das ist ganz spannend und passt halt schönerweise heute auch hier rein, sind Autos. Da gab es nämlich in der letzten Woche, das ist bekannt geworden, dass tatsächlich ein Auto gehackt worden ist und man damit machen kann, was man will von außen. Wer es das genau ist, wird uns jetzt vielleicht Andreas, wenn ich es richtig in Ordnung habe, erzählen, was da passiert ist.
Genau. Also es ist eigentlich eine Geschichte, die für jeden, der sich mit Computersicherheit auskennt, völlig offensichtlich ist. So ein modernes Auto hat jede Menge Computer an Bord. Und Computer, wir beherrschen halt die Technologie noch nicht wirklich, Computer ohne Sicherheitslücken zu bauen. Ergo kann man Autos auch hacken. Das war natürlich erstmal graue Theorie, bis einige Leute angefangen haben, sich tatsächlich damit zu beschäftigen. Es gibt ein paar im Untergrund, die machen das schon länger. Die erzählen in der Regel dann darauf ab, den Tachostand zurückzudrehen und ähnliche Geschichten. Darum geht es nicht, sondern es geht darum, was kann man denn sonst noch so mit so modernen Autos machen, wenn man irgendwie die Kontrolle drüber hat. Und Charlie Miller und Chris Wallaseck haben also schon vor zwei Jahren angefangen, sich das mal näher anzugucken. Und es gab dann die ersten Veröffentlichungen, wo sie jedes Auto hat so einen Wartungsstecker. Habt ihr vielleicht schon mal gesehen. OBD2 Stecker heißt, der ist in der Nähe des Lenkrades. Da haben sie einen Stecker reingesteckt und dann mal angefangen mit den Paketen rumzuspielen, die sie so auf den Bussen gesehen haben. Die haben jetzt einen Stecker dran.
Pakete, Busse, was?
Ja, ja, so ein modernes Auto ist also nicht nur, da ist nicht nur ein Computer drin, da sind ganz, ganz viele Computer drin. Die heißen da nicht Computer, die heißen ECUs. Was mal für Engine Control Unit stand, mittlerweile Electronic Control Unit heißt, weil nicht nur die Engine damit gesteuert wird, sondern alles. Also wenn man sein Auto aufschraubt, so Kästen, wo Drähte rauskommen. Und davon hat es ein modernes Auto bis zu 70 mit auch teilweise sehr beeindruckender Rechenleistung, weil die eine ganze Menge machen. Das ist, also geht los mit dem Mäusekino, das heißt irgendwie das Armaturenbrett, das man hat, da ist ein Computer dran, der das steuert. Geht weiter mit dem Entertainment System, also das Radio, das Navigationssystem, das ist auch ein Computer. Die eigentliche Motorsteuerung, weil elektronische Einspritzung, was man da heutzutage alles hat. Und das ABS-System, das Airbag-System, das kleine Ding, das hinten den Scheibenwischer an- und ausmacht, die Abstandsensoren, die Servolenkung, also die Liste ist mittlerweile echt lang. Und je teuer das Auto, desto mehr hat man davon. Und die sind miteinander verbunden, die müssen natürlich auch miteinander reden, über sogenannte Busse. Also im Prinzip Datenkabel, auf denen sie Informationen austauschen. Der klassische Bus im Fahrzeugbereich, der sogenannte CAN-Bus, C-A-N. Bei modernen Autos gibt es da noch ein paar mehr Typen, unter anderem Flexray und LIN. Und das Ding ist, dass beim Design dieser Autos eigentlich das Maßgebliche war, die Sicherheit im Sinne von Safety. Das heißt, es soll nicht plötzlich gegen eine Wand fahren oder plötzlich das Gaspedal runterdrücken, obwohl man es gar nicht gedrückt hat, wie bei Toyota. Und die Dinger vertrauen einander. Das heißt, auf dem Bus, wenn einer sagt, ich bin das Gaspedal und der Fahrzeugführer möchte gerne, dass das Auto schneller fährt, dann sagt die Motorsteuerung, okay, habe ich wahrgenommen. Ich sag mal der Einspritzpumpe Bescheid, dass sie ein bisschen mehr Benzin geben soll und Luftzufuhr dreh ich auch auf. Also so ungefähr funktionieren moderne Autos. Siehst du mal wie früher, dass man aufs Gaspedal tritt und dann ist da so ein Draht, der eine Klappe am Vergaser zieht. So ein Auto habt ihr bestimmt auch alle mal gefahren, wenn ihr alt genug seid. Sondern ist alles drahtlos. Selbst die Lenkung ist mittlerweile bei vielen Autos indirekt. Man dreht am Lenkrad und ob jetzt nach halb der Lenkraddrehung das Rad doll bewegt oder bloß ein bisschen bewegt, hängt von der Geschwindigkeit ab, mit der man fährt. Aus Sicherheitsgründen, dass man auf der Autobahn nicht so leicht die Spur verliert und so weiter und so fort. Die Bremsen funktionieren so, also früher war es auch mal ein Hydrauliksystem, man hat aufs Pedal getreten und dann hat man einen kleinen Kolben reingedrückt, wo dann per Öldruck die Bremsbacken auf die Bremse gedrückt wurden. Das ist heute auch nicht mehr so, man hat da ein Pedal, da tritt man drauf und dann geht ein Signal an die Bremse. Ich glaube aus Backup-Gründen haben sie immer noch eine Hydraulik, aber die wird eigentlich von der Bremsunterstützung, also naja größtenteils macht es der Computer. Und all das funktioniert über diese kleinen Kommandos und all das setzt voraus, wir sind hier alle gutmütige Teilnehmer im Elektroniksystem. Was die gemacht haben, ist sich auf diese Busse drauf zu hängen und zu sagen, ich bin übrigens auch das Gaspedal und der hat jetzt ganz doll Gas gegeben. Oder ich bin der Schalter vorne im Armaturenbrett, mach doch mal bitte die Fenster runter. Da gibt es also von vor zwei Jahren die ersten Videos, wo sie Journalist fährt Auto und die beiden Hacker sitzen mit ihren Laptops hacken, grinsen auf der Rückbank und tipp tipp tipp tipp enter und plötzlich bremst das Auto und so nummern. Also schon gezeigt, was eigentlich völlig klar ist, wenn man sich die Architektur des Autos anguckt, aber wie das immer so ist, damit die Leute es verstehen, muss man es auch mal zeigen.
Okay, warte. Und bei dieser Sache vor zwei Jahren mussten sie in dem Auto sitzen und mussten mit dem, den Rechner per Kabel mit dem Auto verbinden.
Genau.
Und was dann passiert ist, erzählen wir nach den Nachrichten über Wetter und Verkehr.
Das ist ja fast wie über Buzzfeed hier.
So sieht's aus.
Also wenn Berlin was kann, dann ja wohl die drei großen F. Feste, Feiern und Flughäfen.
Also lasst uns Feste feiern.
Ein legendäres Festival auf einem legendären Flughafen. Und das zum ersten Mal in Europa.
Britz präsentiert das Lollapalooza Festival.
Mit den Beatstakes Sam Smith, Bastille und Siv. Mit Martin Garrix, Deichkind und Macklemore featuring Ryan Lewis. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle.
Samstag 12.
und Sonntag 13. September. Auf dem Flughafen Tempelhof.
So lange es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall wo es Karten gibt. Fritz Nachrichten.
Mit Timo Maschewski.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft hat Ermittlungen gegen zwei Journalisten wegen Landesverrats eingeleitet. Die beiden arbeiten für den Blog netzpolitik.org. Dort haben sie Informationen und Dokumente des Verfassungsschutzes online gestellt, die teilweise als geheim eingestuft waren. In den Dokumenten gibt es um eine Ausweitung der Überwachung von sozialen Netzwerken. Der Gründer von netzpolitik.org, Beckettal, sagte Fritz, man habe zeigen wollen, wie skuppellos die Bundesregierung versuche, die Überwachung trotz der Snowden-Enthüllungen weiter auszubauen. Die Bereitschaft der Deutschen, neue Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen, ist gesunken. Im neuen ARD Deutschland-Trend haben zwar 57% der Befragten gesagt, sie seien für eine Beibehaltung oder Steigerung der Aufnahme zahlen. Auf der anderen Seite ist aber der Anteil der Menschen gestiegen, die wollen, dass künftig weniger Menschen aufgenommen werden. 38% haben das gesagt, das sind 17% mehr als noch Anfang des Jahres. Beim Computersystem des Berliner Senats gibt es anscheinend eine Sicherheitslücke. Nach Informationen der RWB-Abendschau laufen rund 200-320 Server so rum, der Verwaltung noch mit dem veralteten Windows 2003. Dafür stellt der Hersteller Microsoft seit zwei Wochen keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr zur Verfügung. Experten befürchten deshalb, dass Hacker über Schwachstellen in dieses Thema eindringen und Daten abgreifen könnten. In Nigeria hat das Militär rund 60 Geiseln aus der Hand der Islamistengruppe Boko Haram befreit. Unter den Geretteten sind überwiegend Frauen und Kinder. Sie waren von den Islamisten in zwei Lagern im Nordwesten Nigérias festgehalten worden. Boko Haram versucht seit Jahren mit Gewaltanschlägen und Entführungen einen islamischen Staat in Nigeria aufzubauen.
Das Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Steglitz sind es 13 Grad und in Pankow 14 Grad, Rangsdorf meldet 12 Grad, Frankfurt oder 13 Grad, in Falkensee sind es 14 Grad und in Manchano noch 15 Grad. Die Nacht über klart der Himmel stellenweise auf, vor allem im Norden sehen aber auch einige Wolkenfälle dadurch. Trotzdem bleibt es meistens trocken und es kann sich noch bis auf 8 Grad abkühlen. Morgen viel Sonne, vor allem im Süden. Dazu Höchstwerte bis 22 Grad. Und auch das Wochenende geht's freundlich weiter. Es wird auch wieder etwas wärmer. Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der A111 der Stadtautobahn. Statt auswärts ist der Tunnel Ortskern Tegel komplett gesperrt. Da wird die Fahrbahn neu gemacht. In Tegel gibt's außerdem Probleme auf der Gorki-Straße, im Bereich Buddestraße, da gehen die S-Bahnschranken nicht mehr hoch. Auch mehrere BVG-Buslinien müssen umgeleitet werden. Das soll wohl auch noch die ganze Nacht so bleiben. In Brandenburg gibt's Probleme auf der A2-Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Lenin und Netzen wird gebaut. Da ist nur eine Spur frei und das kann etwas länger dauern. Und auch auf der A10, dem östlichen Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck-Sprayau gibt's Probleme. Da ist zwischen Rüdersdorf und Erkner die linke Spur nur noch frei. Wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Oder diesen Sound. Dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Maurice Geider. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Herzlich willkommen zur letzten halben Stunde Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Dabei sind Danimo vom Chaos Computer Club, hallo und guten Abend. Andreas Bruck. Und Erdgeist.
Schönen guten Abend.
Erdgeist wollte gerade noch was zu den Nachrichten sagen.
Nein, ich hatte mich nur an den Blog ein wenig gestört. Das heißt das Blog.
Völlig richtig.
So aber eigentlich geht es heute um Sicherheitslücken und wie man damit umgehen kann. Wir haben schon in den vergangenen 90 Minuten darüber geredet. Wie das funktioniert, wie die Verantwortung voller Umgang damit aussieht, wie man verhindern kann, dass der eigene Code von den Bösen verwendet wird. Und wir reden jetzt gerade darüber, was für Auswirkungen es eigentlich haben kann, wenn es solche Sicherheitslücken gibt und dass es da auch mittlerweile mehr geht als Computer. Wir sind gerade beim Auto angekommen und Andreas hatte gerade schon erklärt, was beim Auto eigentlich alles mittlerweile von einem Computer gesteuert wird. Und die Kurzzusammenfassung ist alles. Und jetzt hat auch schon erzählt, vor zwei Jahren haben Hacker zum ersten Mal gezeigt, dass sie das auch alles irgendwie selbst von ferne steuern können. Und von ferne war damals aber noch, man muss in dem Auto drin sitzen und dann ein Kabel in das Auto reinlegen und dann kann man das System irgendwie hacken. Aber was ist dann passiert, Andreas?
Es ist etwas passiert, was euch alle völlig überraschen wird. Also wie wir alle wissen, so Computer können gehackt werden und Computer, die man ans Internet hängt, können übers Internet gehackt werden. Um es mal ein bisschen vereinfacht darzustellen, aber nicht völlig falsch. Und jetzt sind die Automobilhersteller also auf die glorios Idee gekommen, dass so ein Auto am Internet eigentlich auch eine ganz tolle Sache wäre. Aus verschiedenen Gründen, unter anderem damit übers Internet jederzeit keine Ahnung, aktuelle Verkehrsmeldungen abgerufen werden können, aber auch damit man seinen Twitter-Feed angucken kann.
Oder damit du mit dem Handy dein Auto entsperren kannst.
Genau, dass man aus der Ferne schon mal über die App in seinem Mobiltelefon die Standheizung anmachen will, damit man einen warmen Hintern hat, wenn man des Winters in sein Auto einsteigt. Also der Anwendungsfälle gibt es da viele. Und jetzt haben tatsächlich auch wieder Miller und Wallasec gezeigt, erstmal einem Wire-Journalisten, weil man muss ja ein bisschen trommeln. Und nächste Woche gibt es in Las Vegas die Präsentation dazu, dass das durchaus auch aus der Ferne mit solchen Autos funktioniert, da alles zu tun, was man tun möchte, wenn sie im Internet dranhängen. Konkret handelt es sich um ein Modell des Herstellers Chrysler mit der Marke Jeep, also ein Jeep Cherokee, der da angegriffen wurde, der verfügt über einen Feature namens Uconnect, was halt genau diese Internet-Schnittstelle ist. Und was sie also gezeigt haben unter ein bisschen zweifelhaften, sehr spektakulären Bedingungen, nämlich auf einem befahrenen Highway mit einem Journalisten drin, der dieses Auto durch die Gegend fuhr, ist, wie sie übers Internet in das Auto eingegriffen haben. Also erstmal die Musik laut gedreht, dann die Fenster runter gemacht und dann plötzlich Gas weggenommen, sodass das Auto also auf dem Highway immer langsamer wurde und irgendwann stehen blieb. Und was natürlich auch beliebige andere Möglichkeiten für die Erzeugung von Unfällen mit solchen Autos beinhaltet. Also eigentlich ein sehr, sehr heikles Thema und eine große Gefahr, die übersteht.
So, und jetzt haben wir einen Punkt, wo wir wieder bei der Sicherheitszirkue zurückkommen. Die haben das ja entdeckt und die haben auch schon, also man muss auch sagen, die haben das an dem Jeep Cherokee gezeigt, weil der sozusagen die beste Angriffsmöglichkeit geboten hat. Die haben aber eine Liste von Autos und es gibt noch ein anderes Modell, was genauso leicht angegriffen werden kann und dann so, wo es halt immer schwieriger wird. Aber das ist halt kein bedauerlicher Einzelfall, sondern das ist das, was jetzt auf uns zukommt. Und die haben aber mit der Firma auch schon geredet.
Genau, die sind vorher dahin gelaufen, haben also das getan, was man Responsible Disclosure nennt. Vorher hat der Firma Bescheid gesagt, so wir werden das jetzt veröffentlichen. Und dann gab es wahrscheinlich Heulen und Wehklagen. Und die Firma Chrysler hat jetzt sich entschlossen, USB-Sticks mit Updates an alle ihre Kunden zu verschicken. Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, man kriegt einen Brief, da ist ein USB-Stick drin. Den steckt man dann an seinem Auto in den USB-Slot, wo man sonst sein iPhone anhängt oder sein Memorystick für die MP3s reinsteckt. Und dann sagt das Ding, bitte updaten, dann kommt so ein Ladebalken und dann ist irgendwann geupdatet und die Sicherheitslücke ist beseitigt. Betrug 1, 4 Millionen Modelle.
Als Hacker würde ich mir jetzt Adressen von Jeep Cherokee Besitzern suchen und ihnen Briefen mit USB-Sticks schicken.
Das ist die nächste Frage, wie gut ist die Signaturprüfung bei den Updates? Ja, aber auch wieder ein Vektor, ne? Also es gibt verschiedene Angriffsvektoren, über die man an so ein Auto rankommen kann und drahtlos über Internet ist natürlich der bequemste. Aber zu USB-Sticks, da sind ja jede Menge Daten drauf, die dann vom Navi oder was auch immer gelesen werden. Also einen Fall ist mir bekannt, da kann man per USB-Stick, sondern unter Points of Interest ins Navigationssystem einspielen. Also man klickt halt auf der Karte irgendwie, ja, da wohnt ich, da wohnt die Oma und dann kann man da ein XML-Datei draus machen und die da reinstecken. Und wenn man die XML-Datei geschickt gestaltet, dann stürzt das System halt ab. Und das ist also durchaus vorstellbar, dass man eine Sicherheitslücke findet, die sich darüber ausnutzen lässt, dass jemand etwas in das USB reinsteckt.
Und jetzt ist der Punkt, die sind halt zu dieser Firma gegangen und haben gesagt, hier ist Sicherheitslücke, dann veröffentlicht sie das jetzt, es gibt diese USB-Sticks. Aber wenn man so mal nachguckt, wie realistischerweise, wie viele Leute Updates machen, dann ist halt auf jeden Fall klar, es wird in näherer Zukunft zwei Sachen eingetreten sein, weil es wird Autos geben, die nicht geupdatet wurden und es wird relativ breites Wissen darüber vorhanden sein, wie die Sicherheitslücken funktionieren.
Davon ist auszugehen, zumal wir in einer Situation leben, wo wenn man mit seinem Auto zum TÜV fährt, sich niemand die Versionsstände der Software anguckt. Also es findet ja nicht mal eine Prüfung statt, ob man denn auch mit allen Patches durch die Gegend fährt oder vielleicht mal wieder updaten muss. Also ganzen Probleme, die wir von Rechnern so kennen, die wir mit dem nächsten Auto auch haben.
So, jetzt ist aber der Punkt und dann sind wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen Thema, die Sendung, nämlich dem Umgang mit Sicherheitsschwankungen. Was macht man denn als Hacker? Also man ist jetzt Hacker und hat halt so sein System komplett auseinandergenommen und hat jetzt so eine Wahl, wie man es macht. Und jetzt ist so die, jetzt finde ich ja, ist was die jetzt gemacht haben, nämlich als erster Firma gehen und der Zeit lassen. Und dann kann man halt sagen, okay, die habt's ja gewusst und so. Aber die nehmen ja, man könnte sagen, die nehmen ja trotzdem in Kauf, dass jetzt diese Leute mit den ungepatchten Autos rumfahren und die Sicherheitslücke bekannt ist. Also warum wird das überhaupt an die Öffentlichkeit bringen?
Ja, vermutlich. Also erstens, dass ich die Sicherheitslücke entdecke, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass nicht jemand an, dass sie nicht auch schon entdeckt hat. Und zum zweiten auch, um überhaupt auf das Problem aufmerksam zu machen. Also gerade in dem Fall, man kann jetzt über die Mittel diskutieren. Ja, auf einer tatsächlich befahrenen Straße das auszuprobieren ist grenzwertig. Aber auf jeden Fall hat das in der Industrie eine Debatte losgetreten. Das ist irgendwie ein Problem, das lange Zeit stiefmütterlich betrachtet wurde. Also gerade bei den ersten Veröffentlichungen vor ein oder zwei Jahren, da gibt es einen VW-Presse-Sprecher, der sich hinstellt und sagt, irgendwie ist alles viel zu kompliziert. Das wird nie in der Praxis einer machen oder ähnliche Geschichten. Oder es heißt, unsere Autos sind unhackbar, hört man halt ständig. Und das überhaupt angefangen wird, darauf Wert zu legen und auch die Ressourcen dafür zu alluzieren, dass die Autos entsprechend gehärtet werden, dass Sicherheitslücken gesucht und gepatcht werden, dass Update-Mechanismen eingerichtet werden, dass vielleicht demnächst der TÜV mal anfängt, Versionsstände zu kontrollieren. Das erfordert einen gewissen öffentlichen Druck. Und in dem Fall ist es eine Abwägung, die ganz, ganz klar ist. Es ist ein Patch draußen. Die Information, wie man die Lücke ausnutzt, ist noch nicht komplett draußen. Da müssen wir mal gucken, wie viel da überhaupt rausgeht. Aber es wurde gezeigt, dass es geht. Und da kann man natürlich spekulieren, wenn man weiß, dass es geht. Wen gibt es denn noch, der sowas kann und vielleicht damit Schindluder treibt? Genauso gut könnte ja ein Hacker hingehen und sagen, naja, ich richte eine Webseite ein im Darknet. Und da kann man dann 1000 Bitcoin bezahlen und mir eine Vehicle ID geben. Und dann fährt dieses Auto gegen den Baum. Ist ja auch ein vorstellbares Geschäftsmodell. Und das will man ja verhindern, dass sowas nicht passiert als Gesellschaft. Und dafür muss man nicht Strukturen schaffen. Dazu muss man auch mal über Sicherheitslücken reden.
Na ja, jetzt sagst du als Gesellschaft Strukturen schaffen. Aber das, was man erlebt und was jetzt auch so zu sagen, was du denkst, ist ja der, das ist ein relativ kleiner Kreis von Leuten, die das verhandeln. Nämlich sozusagen auf der einen Seite die Hacker, auf der anderen Seite die wenigen Entscheider in der Industrie, die dann sagen können, okay wir forschen daran, wir verlassen das halt lieber. Das ist ja keine gesellschaftliche Debatte.
Na doch, da ist ja ein gewisser Druck dazwischen. Also interessiert das die Leute oder interessiert das die Leute nicht, dass man halt aus der Ferne das Auto gegen den Baum fahren lassen kann?
Schau dir die Diskussion an, die es gab im Zusammenhang mit einer Untersuchung, die der ADAC dann in Auftrag gegeben hat. Da ging es um das Remote, aufschließen von einem gewissen Fahrzeugtyp. Das war dann auch eine Aktion, die der ADAC wirklich quasi begleitet hat und überhaupt erst ermöglicht hat, dass man das ausprobiert. Und ich würde jetzt mal diskutieren im Kontext Autos, ist der ADAC schon als Teil der Gesellschaft oder als Teil der relevanten Gesellschaft in dem Fall zu betrachten? Also das ist größer als jetzt nur ein paar Nerds und ein paar Manager, finde ich schon. Nur in dem einen Fall, aber ist das immer so? Es ist letztendlich, wie du schon sagtest, eine Fallgeschichte, aber je mehr es passiert, desto krasser die Beispiele. Also sowas lebt natürlich immer auch von medialer Aufmerksamkeit. Mediale Aufmerksamkeit kriegst du je krasser dein Hack ist. Aber die mediale Aufmerksamkeit ist ja völlig unabhängig davon, ob du die tatsächliche Anleitung veröffentlicht, die mediale Aufmerksamkeit in dem Fall ist ja dadurch gegeben, dass du dieses krassere Beispiel machst, dass du sagst, hier der Typ sitzt in einem Auto und beschreibt halt, wie krass das für ein Gefühl ist, wenn du mitten auf der Autobahn bist, dann wird das Auto auf einmal langsamer. Das ist ja völlig egal, ob jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit ist, wie das genau funktioniert oder nicht.
Da ist ja die Geschichte. Tatsächlich ist ja die Information, wie das genau funktioniert, noch gar nicht raus.
Aber das ist doch angekündigt, dass sie das machen wollen.
Ich weiß nicht, in welches Detail das geht.
Sie haben eine Deadline gesetzt, aber haben nicht gesagt, inwiefern sie das veröffentlichen werden. Sie werden das auf einer Sicherheitskonferenz veröffentlichen. Aber sie haben noch nicht einen gesagt, zumindest nicht öffentlich, bis zu welchen Details sie das tun werden.
Ich lese über uns gerade einen Tweet von einem der Hacker. Offensichtlich hat Chrysler einen Weg gefunden, wie sie für ungepätschte Fahrzeuge den Internetzugang unterbinden können. Möglicherweise ist da der Stöpsel gefunden, den man reinstecken kann, dass da nichts Schlimmes passiert. Auch bei ungepätschten Fahrzeugen, dass die Leute gezwungen werden, einen Patch einzuspielen.
Ach so, also man sagt, kein automatischer Patch, aber man sagt einem ungepätschten Auto, du bist nicht mehr im Internet drin, bevor du gepätscht bist.
Genau.
Das ist ja immerhin eine Lösung.
Das wäre ja auch immer ganz praktisch für so Rechner zu Hause bei den Leuten, die ihre solvenliche Abdehnung halten.
Das machen ISPs ja teilweise, alleine um sich selber zu schützen. Die machen einfach gewisse Ports oder sogar ganze Verbindungen, also ganze koppelnde Haushalte ab. Wie, wenn die kontrollieren auf dem Rechner, welches Software da läuft? Nein, nein. Wenn die einen Angriff feststellen, der aufgrund einer Sicherheitslücke erst möglich ist, dann gibt es ISPs, soweit ich weiß nicht, unbedingt in Deutschland, die würden dann einfach präventiv Ports schließen, soweit das möglich ist, aber in anderen Ländern ist das durchaus üblich. Dann einfach zuzumachen, gerade um sich selber zu schützen.
Was es für Firmen tatsächlich gibt, ist so ein Agent, der auf dem Rechner läuft und der guckt, ob alles gepatcht ist. Erst wenn alles gepatcht ist, sagt er dem Netzwerk alles gut. Wenn nicht alles gut ist, dann nimmt man ein Quarantänennetzwerk und kann nichts machen, außer Patches einzuspielen. Man darf erst alles eigentliche Firmenetzwerk, doch, doch wirklich.
Das und ein VN-Scan, ja.
Dann darf man erst an die eigentlichen Firmen daten dran, wenn man alles gepatcht hat.
Das klingt gut für den Rest der Familie, die sich nicht selber um den Rechner kümmern wollen. Aber ich finde noch eine andere Frage nicht unspannend, und zwar, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, ist die Untersuchung, die diese beiden Leute gemacht haben, ein Forschungsprojekt von der DARPA. Das ist wiederum in den USA. Die Leute sind die so, auch vor allem an Militärforschung, irgendwie viel Eigennutzen haben.
Das ist der Forschungsarm des US-Militärs, kann man sagen.
Genau.
Das heißt, alle Autos sind per Computer gesteuert, der Forschungsarm des Militärs bezahlt, dass diese Sicherheitslücken rauskommen. Das hatte so ein bisschen Geschmack, insbesondere, wo am Anfang der Sendung gesagt wurde, eigentlich wollen wir gar nicht, dass Militärs mit unseren Sicherheitslücken was zu tun haben, geschweige denn die ausnutzen können. Und dann die spannende Frage, die ich finde, die dahintersteckt, ist, wenn wir wollen, dass Sicherheitslücken verantwortungsvoll damit umgegangen wird, dann müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass Sicherheitslücken von Leuten gefunden werden, die überhaupt damit verantwortungsvoll umgehen wollen. Die müssen aber auch von irgendwas leben. Brauchen wir also so eine Art staatliches Sicherheitslückenforschungsteam?
Ja, da muss man dann immer wieder Angst haben, dass sie das nicht veröffentlichen. Also das mit DARPA ist eine spannende Geschichte. Das wird da auch ein bisschen anders gesehen als hier. Also hier ist es schon androhig, wenn man vom Militär Geld nimmt. Da ist es völlig normal. Da lässt jeder sein Forschungsprojekt von der DARPA finanzieren.
Aber bei uns haben wir doch das BSI, das genau dafür da ist.
Ja, tun die das? Nee, die machen keine Forschungsförderung. Doch, doch, doch.
Weiß nicht wie zufällig, ja genau.
DARPA hat zum Beispiel auch die Forschung fürs Internet finanziert. Also meine Meinung ist, wenn das Forschungsergebnis hinterher allen zur Verfügung steht, der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung steht und nicht irgendwo in einem Tresor verschwindet, dann darf das, finde ich, auch das Militär bezahlen. Das finde ich völlig in Ordnung.
Es gibt da dieses Internet, das nicht zuletzt von der DARPA überhaupt erst gebaut wurde.
Es hat sich bei Sicherheitslücken im Computerbereich dieses Bug Bounty Ding etabliert. Also die Firmen sagen, wenn du als Außenstehender uns eine Sicherheitslücke reportest, dann gibt es da Geld dafür. Und das ist tatsächlich was, wovon manche Leute lieben. Wenn man bei Pwn2O mitmacht, dann kann man auch mal 100.000, 150.000 Euro abräumen. Normalerweise, wenn man eine Sicherheitslücke an Pwn2O reportet...
Aber da kannst du schon wieder zu Problemen kommen, dass das Wasser nahe abkommt, wenn man das auch schon sprachend da reinfunkt, oder?
In der Tat. Die Probleme werden den Leuten gerade bewusst. Das ist alles nochmal auf den Prüfstand gestellt und zurückgestellt. Da werden wir sicherlich noch ein bisschen Bewegung drin sehen, was da passiert und wie das funktionieren wird. Aber im Prinzip ist diese Bug Bounty Geschichte ein sehr richtiger Ansatz. Man sieht halt ein, so Sicherheitsforschung kostet Zeit. Und Kenntnis über eine Sicherheitslücke ist Geld wert. Und das ist meistens auch für den Hersteller billiger, tatsächlich diese Sicherheitslücke zu kaufen, als den Imageschaden in Kauf zu nehmen, wenn mal wieder alles gehackt wird darüber. Also die 10.000, 15.000 Dollar, das interessiert die ja in dem Sinne nicht. Das ist für die kein Geld im großen Maßstab. Aber dann mal wieder 5% Markteinteile an den Konkurrenten zu verlieren, das ist richtig Geld.
Okay, könnt ihr vielleicht noch zum Abschluss sagen, einen generellen Leitfaden für den, wie Hacker verantwortungsvoll mit Sicherheitslücken und dem Finden derselben umgehen sollten, geben? Wollt ihr das jeder Einzelnen machen oder gibt es eine einheitliche Meinung?
Das ist glaube ich...
Also ich würde so ein Auto, das ich erstmal aufgemacht habe, oder wenn ich das großflächig habe, dann würde ich mir auf dem Weg zur Arbeit erstmal eine Gasse freibachen. So ganz dezent nach links und rechts lenken lassen, dann kann man damit durchfahren. Das ist doch praktisch.
Oder so ein Physical Botnet, also man stellt sich bloß vor, man drückt auf den Knopf und es fahren 1000 S-Klasse vor.
Ich dachte jetzt eigentlich, ihr sagt zum Schluss noch etwas verantwortungsvolles für den angehenden Jungen Hacker, der vielleicht...
Vielleicht doch. Die All-Days meist bieten zu verkaufen im Untergrund, halte ich persönlich für moralisch nicht vertretbar. Ob der Kaufer jetzt, ob das Kriminelle sind, die einem versuchen, einen Trojaner unter zu jubeln, um das Bankkonto leer zu räumen. Ob das irgendwelche Firmen sind, die für zweifelhafte Geheimdienste noch zweifelhafter Länder über Wachenssoftware programmieren. Ob das die nächste, in Anführungszeichen, Cyberbombe ist, die dann dafür sorgt, dass in einem Land der Strom komplett ausfällt. Das ist für mich alles kein verantwortungsvoller Umgang. Ich finde, man hat meiner Meinung nach die freie Wahl zwischen Full Disclosure und Responsible Disclosure. Und musste einfach ein bisschen abwägen, was im Einzelfall der bessere Weg ist. Microsoft wurde tatsächlich mit Full Disclosure dazu gezwungen, sich mein Sicherheitsprogramm zuzulegen. Also überhaupt sich darum zu kümmern. Zu XP-Zeiten war das richtig schlimm. Dann haben Leute angefangen, einmal die Woche eine Sicherheitslücke zu veröffentlichen. Bis Bill Gates persönlich gesagt hat, mir reicht's. Die ganze Firma macht jetzt einen Monat lang nichts anderes außer Sicherheit. Da wurde das besser. Dann haben sie angefangen Mitigations zu bauen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, Code-Outlets anzufangen usw. Bug Bounties immer gut, kann man mitnehmen. Also Full Disclosure machen, wenn der Hersteller unkooperativ ist, anfängt zu drohen, einfach eine Sicherheitslücke raushauen. Wenn es ein kooperativer Hersteller ist, Responsible Disclosure informieren, möglichst Bug Bounty abgreifen und den Ruhm und die Ehre gibt es hinterher immer noch.
Genau. Und wie gesagt, die Bug Bounties sind durchaus in einer Höhe, wo man sagen kann, da kann man, das ist schon mehr. Also das ist schon mehr als ein kleines Zubrot. Je nachdem, wie viele man findet und wie häufig man sie findet. Also da jetzt zu sagen, naja, ich muss da jetzt irgendwie einen Geheimdienst verticken, weil das ist so viel Arbeit gewesen, das zu finden, das hört man häufig als Erklärung. Und ich frag mich dann auch immer, wie die Leute gepolt sind. Okay, seid verantwortungsvoll mit Sicherheitslücken, falls ihr sie findet. Wir haben über den Umgang damit heute sehr viel gehört. Ihr könnt euch diese ganze Sendung auch nochmal als Podcast anhören, wenn ihr wollt. Er scheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de und dann irgendwann später auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Es will die Tradition, dass zum Schluss der Sendung noch ein paar Dinge angesagt werden. Insbesondere ist vom 13. bis 17. August ein Chaos Communication Camp. Wer möchte dazu noch etwas sagen?
Na wir gehen halt selten mitten in der Pampa im Ziegleipark Mildenberg. Das ist sozusagen das inverse Berlin, weil da hat sich an der Havel damals Ton abgelagert. Und dementsprechend wurden da Ziegeleien gebaut, wo Ziegel gebrannt wurden. Und jetzt gibt es da ganz ganz viele Seen, die zu gelaufenen Tage bauten für den Leben. Und das inverse Berlin, weil das wurde alles nach Berlin geschafft, nach oben gebaut. Also mitten in dieser historischen Industriearchitektur werden wir zelten. Wenig Strom, wenig Wasser, dafür viel Sonne haben und viel Spaß.
Und tatsächlich Internet. Und ganz kurz, wir haben auch... Aber warte mal, ihr fahrt dahin, ne? Ja. Aber ansonsten kann da keiner mehr hinfahren, weil die Tickets ausverkauft haben. Ja, aber die Leute, die keine Tickets haben, können auf jeden Fall zumindest die Vorträge, die dort laufen, über Streaming verfolgen. Das werden wir haben.
Ja, ganz wichtige Ansage. Es gibt morgen 22 Uhr mittel europäischer Sommerzeit nochmal einen Schwung Tickets, nämlich die Tickets, die die Leute nicht bezahlt haben, kommen nochmal in den Verkauf. Es gibt also nochmal eine Chance, hinzukommen.
Okay. Und die andere Nachricht, die es noch gab, war, es gibt einen kleinen Hacker Space in Berlin, der ein Problem hat. Genau, die Raumfahrt Agentur. Die wird nämlich aus verschiedenen Gründen, aus ihrer bisherigen Behausung rausgekantet und sucht jetzt dringend neue Flächen im Wedding. Und wer immer da gute Ideen hat, auf der Homepage der Raumfahrt Agentur findet sich da ein Aufruf. Wenn ihr da Ideen habt, wenn ihr wisst, ah Mensch, da gibt es eine schöne Fläche, die steht zur Verfügung, schaut euch doch mal um. Ansonsten sucht die Raumfahrt Agentur auch immer noch Unterstützer, die Mitglied werden wollen, um diesen Umzug zu stemmen. Das ist nämlich jetzt sehr, sehr kurzfristig alles. Und es wäre schade, wenn das da nicht weitergehen würde. Alles klar, dann wird es dir Bescheid. Ihr könnt euch gerne an die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club wenden, wenn euch etwas davon interessiert. Chaosradio.ccc.de, die Webseite zur Sendung. Ich danke den Anwesenden fürs Hiersein erklären und diskutieren, insbesondere Herrn Erdgeist. Dem Herrn Danimo. Und dem Herrn Andreas Boop. Immer wieder ein großes Vergnügen. Wir verabschieden uns von hier, übergeben dann an Flo Heiler, der im Nightfly euch wahrscheinlich elektronisch verstärkte Gitarrenmusik um die Ohren werfen wird. Ich gehe mal ganz stark davon aus. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich verabschiede mich auch. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.